can I regret this yes okay
sometimes when you're under quarantine
and we have nothing to do you know what
the problem is my hair if I get rid of
my hair I'll have time to think about
other things so right now on the
streamlining now here's the other thing
hey you look like Joe Pesci when he
burned his head and home alone okay
here's the other problem I took my
manscape I decided to do a little trim
oh that is it why stop there let's go
let's hit the pubic machine the piece I
didn't know it'd be that tight yep the
filly fade on your collar 53 with very
few with basically no fuse now that's
not appropriate
apparently people under 30 it's very
common for men shave their whole body
I've always had pubes
and now manscape brought me down so
health meds dude shoutout to manscape
sorry right that's what I have going on
I didn't shorten things up a little bit
oh oh and then I got I got I gotta be
consistent all the way around so crystal
he looked at me and said oh that look
how good that looks that looks really
good now you should have been sporting
that for the past ten years but you
didn't because you're a [ __ ] idiot
so so we complimented me and then it's a
nice day that's why my hair is
definitely Lea it's just not like sea
otter scouts not even I could cut it for
you I'm not even know it's not even it
was like some spittle sprigs sticking
out well I'll feed you up you know you
can paint it up yeah he owns it looks
like you gonna Rob you though
yeah well Brian looks like the worst
extra from Full Metal Jacket
[Laughter]
you really don't barely see or yeah it
almost looks like a hat imprint uh-huh
but it never let me see B but your
Rogen's is thick your knees haven't had
a couple all right it's tough yours
looks good it does do that look if
you're in a focus if you're in the brain
if you're in the mood you know sleep
digestive health support vitality
essential nutrients which well looks
like Brian you want it man take on it
you want to be if you want if you're 53
and you want to look 50 if you've ever
watched home alone and when he burned
his hair off you went I want that look
then [ __ ] don't take on it and don't
take but if you want to look sweet start
taking on it on it calm slash spider 10%
off alpha brain they got vitamins for
your ass tech support I swear by it from
my training yeah we hope you want to be
healthier weight it's freaking about
healthy cool shrimp tech helps you out
with it you want to never go to the gym
and just train from your home it want to
be quarantined for the rest your life do
it do it with on-demand training on it
six barbell on it six bodyweight on it
six kettlebell streaming fitness from
your freakin living room you can do it
on your goddamn phone yeah it's that
easy don't have to talk to anybody you
can do it naked if you want beacon do
drag your balls on the ground workout at
home on at six demand on demand training
on it calm slash fighter temp sent off
[Music]
my kids scream okay so Brendan is
hysterical he's laughing hysterically
because I shaved my head and he thinks
it looks terrible you guys gonna do it
your tongue well he's what do this this
core team was a scoring team that makes
you do weird [ __ ] it makes you do his
[ __ ] IIIi was like I'm gonna shave my
head
I didn't mean to shave my head
I meant to cut it short I was bored and
I said maybe I'll get myself a haircut
with clippers and I'll get the long one
they weren't long enough I liked you it
wasn't bad before right and now I look a
little fuzzy illegally doors pigeon a
pepper stick I noticed my smites my kid
called said you look like an ostrich I
was like and then my daughter screamed
and ran away I was FaceTime wearing
shoes and screaming no I mean no now
you're laughing super hard let me see
what I face a little Swan nope your face
homeboy it could be my face because
usually when my face is not Swan I look
good
meet you you have the rush limbaugh yet
the the dot up there too huh my answer
next year isn't that that's a little
strong well that's very tight huh no one
to iris I brought that I brought my
beard down a little bit and that's the
thing go thick with a beard then we
might be more know dude this is easy fix
you'll figure with the beard and then
just grow your hair back see I didn't
expect it to look like that let me see
the pig that's a that's an issue that's
exactly what I look like isn't it man I
would go for a whole shave just shave it
all off and then grow it out and that
might get really bad so I'm outgoing
Dana White yeah I mean no like it's just
very very finally I want to look like
Rogen uh hey look at me and you know I
love you sometimes you miss weddings you
know it's sometimes you miss Wednesday
it's quarantine to make you do [ __ ] up
[ __ ] Wednesday that's all it is
we're fine sometimes you grow back of
course it'll grow back eventually yeah
after we're able to go outside yeah the
meantime you didn't help me nothing
you're just like I'm gonna do it
daliyah legitimately went you look
really good he's so nice I might beard
or longer and I brought my beard down I
took all the hair here look night I mean
you know I thought your hair look nice
yeah
probably did you but you've had a shaved
head well not seen when I first met you
had a shaved head yeah
little older and grayer so the problem
is when you get gray heads with the gray
beard it's just that I guess they top
this or no it's just a little patchy in
certain areas it's a bit patchy in
certain areas so I've got a and then
there's three here stick in the back
like you're from like Charlie Brown
style yeah it's like sticking out the
back yeah so I'm gonna have to bring
that down to the gray is great yeah
chicks dig great dude keep that up right
girls like gray there's also like hair
so don't do that again
you got a lot of hair got a beard and
hair I should start sporting hat no man
I don't mean to make you feel bad about
your hair
hey you know though I've always felt bad
you've had good hear all you I mean most
your life I mean the last thing I'm
gonna feel is bad no I mean I mean do
you have a Catherine woods number no
okay yeah what's your number cat we're
just clowning Brian's here Mike
Catherwood look at the two you go get it
Mike thick hair let's take a deep good
look at it
well now I'm surrounded by two guys with
very thick hair yeah that's that's not a
lie
mike has better hair than me that's not
true you bought that pretty I like you
with the long hair - oh thanks dude I
like that you both have very good hair
are you wearing a cloth mask cuz drew
told you - um I'm wearing a cloth
maskers I've my bum a little bit scary
are you scared now I mean III don't know
scared I'm not any more scared than I
was say last week when I saw you guys
it's just I don't want to feel like I'm
not doing everything I can
we didn't within reason you know what
I'm saying like and if the government
says wear a mask I'm gonna [ __ ] wear
mad I'm not gonna wear a Michael Jackson
mask so I'm at least gonna yeah go back
to 2003 emo kid with my [ __ ] we're
dropping some fire in the kid bandanas
you know that sick you're welcome
sickness good job
what were you gonna say though I was
gonna seven listening to these doctors
who are on the front line yeah like I
realized that they are so [ __ ]
worried and they are seeing people die I
mean you know I know that the numbers
are what they are but it's really
interesting to hear them because they do
sound stressed and in a world of yeah
don't get to its Coronas a problem 100
cent especially if you're at risk it's a
huge problem it's a real big problem for
the people that are they have to deal
with it all these workers and the
hospital stuff like that it's a big
problem yeah yeah now is it the biggest
problem right now right well my my
question is is there's let's let's not
be crazy let's not deny the fact this is
a very dangerous problem this is harming
people who's killing people yeah we
should definitely be concerned and take
and be focused on on this virus but are
we ignoring a may be as large a problem
in the fact that like the media
definitely has currency in scaring us
more like there's it there right that's
not the route one open for debate
there's a value yeah that these mass
media companies the corporations and
it's not a partisan thing like I think
you know MSNBC is just as guilty as
follow that their their understanding
that there's real currency that their
bottom line is aided by us being way
more scared than maybe necessarily what
I think is interesting is I listen to
both embassy and Fox I do this
experiment and I did I listened to CNN
that I listen to Fox I do it on YouTube
can't handle hair folks up my birth
father O'Brien got Corona I do have a
little chronic I was thinking of a
different virus but yeah yeah what I
noticed that Fox is super pro-business
tiny and you're sure lift Tom Hanks
didn't get Philadelphia baby died over
my head I was gonna say I was gonna say
don flamenco from Mike Tyson's punch-out
yeah if we could bring up garbage so go
through the kid tonk LeMay go and tell
me if that is not Brian with this you
just can't come here with a fresh new
year all right casual they look pretty
similar
yeah he's lonely Rose yeah pretty
similar is here's better I look like Ari
Shaffir right there Oh Ari does look
like him yeah he's a badass I'm sorry
everything all right yeah yeah please go
back to Pai please I'm saying guys
that's gonna happen on and off too
sometimes okay my hair is a little tight
my hair's a little close to the bone we
know this right
and maybe I made a mistake maybe what I
didn't mean to say that I was using a
shaver and I said I'm gonna clip my hair
universally and I'm have a long you know
a long bit on the on the Clipper and
then I realized I went oh that's too
deep
oh no oh boy and then that I had I had
to commit all the way mm-hmm we were all
having fun with it but I mean you look
like you look good
thank you buddy you have a very like
masculine head like there's some people
who I have buddies no there's not
worried about him like yeah it's like
sound like a teakettle
yeah go ahead I got teakettle is the tea
ready is tea ready
he just job you got admit there's a
thing though like some dudes with a
receding hairline and it's like it looks
like you look wimpy he has like the
Bruce Willis
yeah that's like sweet Ellis when he was
younger
now listen yes well but Fox News is way
more they kind of playing it down a
little bit they're favoring sort of
let's get back to work there you go I'm
a Bruce box
[ __ ] [ __ ] eating grin yeah you do
look a little but look how he did it
dude like it like that almost looks
better he's straight big yeah he's great
but yeah see like you should be that
though yeah I can be what that guy right
there but no no no not a success no
though with a bald one you're better
looking at it like she looks good there
you're better looking we got a body too
for sure yes thank you
thanks for the compliment spread it like
a [ __ ] teakettle over here man that's
closer no sawdust Demi Moore's have you
guys seen her Bush in what movie GI Jane
well you yet you stopped I'm sorry to
interrupt you this is worth it Demi
Moore's Bush in nineteen I believe
eighty-three is so big that you will I
guarantee right now when when chin pulls
up these pictures you're gonna say
that's not real it is 100% real
she has acknowledged them it is from we
magazine in the early eighties you hated
me it was a French artistic kind of nude
magazine yeah
herb Madonna I've never seen bushland
here see Madonna no that's Carl
Parisians armpit that's not a bush oh I
feel sick how it's amazing how that Demi
Moore's bullsh y'all that's that's what
girls did back in the day that's not I
disagree Brian you're old enough to know
you know that that [ __ ] existed not like
that is that's whoa that's like
Chewbacca's mouth
yeah oh [ __ ] yeah I would even slow me
down I'm just saying it would be any
touted be tougher your boy here well
because we're so used to just trim do
you keep things very very tight a tight
but not shaped I don't like this kind of
weird wait let keep it let's hot damn it
go back for a second let's go through
cuz I think they have some famous bushes
here Madonna Madonna was working with us
serious what's what famous now Cuba I
think every girl was working with Bush
back then my thing is though that's
that's another well that's impressive
that's a bear's paw yeah it should bear
some more post-its egregious bush well
what's I don't know what's going on
there that was a [ __ ] that's that's
earth well that's cool how ridiculously
hot was she though oh so butan till this
day oh man that's it that's an
attractive that's a trick not there but
yeah I mean she was smoke show yeah how
like service attendant Brendon saying
that he would it would slow him down
that would be comfortable I'm such a
visual guide my day could go not happen
for girls in my zone and I have like I'm
pretty non-discriminating when it comes
to poontang like I like it all but if a
girl's really in my zone there's not
much that could slow me down like really
my left like like murdering my parents
might not slow me down i sat next to
have Demi Moore like 82nd in the movie
theater in Los Santos in Los Angeles
right next door you make a move I didn't
I was with my girlfriend 1986 I was a
year out of high school to go I sat next
to her um it was a summer I think of 86
no it's December okay I was sitting next
to her in the movie theater in Brentwood
or Westwood and I remember just looking
at a clown I know that girl from
somewhere and I was so taken by her I
she's that Rudy I remember me and my
girlfriend was that smoke show but I
just was like a turd that's Demi Moore
and I was waiting outside the bathroom
and she was waiting for her friend and I
was just looking at her god
[ __ ] yeah there's something about eyes
that'll do that to you well certain
girls that do that though and her voice
her voice voices that [ __ ] that oh it's
sex that a heavy
like ah yeah we all we've all met like
really attractive women we've all been
with really attractive women but there's
some level of beauty where it's like
it's disarming you know what I'm saying
where you're around here like oh this is
weird like it's strange yeah yeah you're
almost scared you know I've not
necessarily like the biggest fan her
beauty wise uh uh on TV she's beautiful
clearly but in person I was I was
stunned at how hot Jennifer Aniston is
in person oh really like it's it's how I
saw I've never seen her good Oh cuz her
eyes are so bright blue and she's like
she's in person she's I've heard that
alarm I got from the number I said oh
who did for me was uh I was at a like an
Oscars party and there's everybody
you've ever seen on TV and movies is
there and I'm dressed up like a penguin
and I just like the crowd just like
separated like the [ __ ] Red Sea and
Kate Beckinsale oh yes I was like you
told me that I'm I'm Thai was like oh
they make humans like that I know what
planet is she from yeah yeah there's
there's those people there's obvious
ones too like I hosted the red carpet
for Hancock's that mu and Charlize
Theron in person is like really she's a
tall drink of water though big bird she
should be a girl big bit I've spent some
time with her she's she's strong she
seems cool too and she's really far from
like my tip I like she's really cool
like ethnic brunettes with long hair
that's my like main real go to like an
ass I like Asian latina black with long
hair it is Mike yeah and you fill in the
blank you do the math that means bigger
ass yeah typically I'm not a boob man my
cell I like them like them if they're
there surely that's in it that's a waist
the waist the hips yes yeah yeah katal
yeah it is weird does certain certain
certain women you see them like what
what do not get to admit it I mean you
know it sounds dumb but there's guys
like that too oh they're so good-looking
that you're like well now I'm conscious
of my behavior this is strange
yeah oh dude I mean I've never been
around but Brad Pitt and once put I'm in
Hollywood when he takes off his shirt
like and that so much there but Roy and
Fight Club those don't do it for me
I'm in Hollywood was chill in the car
like a man yes like yeah dude he is he's
kind of but he's cool yeah yeah yes is
the big leather watch band on is the
bracelet and Troy is so gay even though
obviously it's based on a true story
it's still it seems surreal because it's
guys fighting with swords and [ __ ] and
Tyler Durden is a [ __ ] [ __ ] that
takes you out of it halfway through the
movie but something about Once Upon a
Time in Hollywood I'm with I'm a Brendon
on this woman it's like jeans and a
t-shirt [ __ ] you look like you're
like I need balls like a [ __ ] watch
cruising down like the 405 yeah yeah oh
[ __ ] yeah dude yeah they shut down the
90 you know that that's where they that
when he's on the highway rail you shut
down the 90 yeah well yeah reason the
yellow shirt in the glass I'm like [ __ ]
I wish I liked that cool he's um
you know I don't know if we'll have this
type of thing much longer this legit
movie star your massive ælis movie star
where people go to a cinema to see you
and it's a special thing that's not a
crash don't know if that's gonna it's
like him and Leo DiCaprio because you
know don't get me wrong there's amazing
a list super talented leading men you
know a younger generation that Gosling
and Adam drivers one of my my father
he's amazing and you're not gonna but
that there's a thing about like you used
to have it you only got Brad Pitt twice
a year yeah was a narrow my buddy was a
bruiser said was this is ten years ago
even more it's just shocking job it I
see Brian I think it's [ __ ] sick but
um did this producer said he was talking
about what a movie stars
yeah and we were like well then they
were like Morgan Freeman and they were
like he goes not a movie star what
people don't go to the movie to see him
right I like the movie and he went he
went through the hiney list of people
that actually get people to come to a
movie so so the movie stars like Brad
Pitt Tom Cruise leo
Leonarda can might be the last Denzel
Washington sure they were movie stars
where people came there was a number
attached them yeah and they knew people
would go to the movies to see the
that list was so incredibly flammable
Smith yeah all scores an error
Will Smith back in the day I'm saying
this was 15 years ago whatever the
carbon we had this argument and so you
could have these great actors like the
annual day-lewis or you know even even
at the time Sean Penn but they weren't
bringing people into theater that's Dana
White said they don't move the needle
that's a very rare very rare combination
sports star to that it's very rare they
guys branch on either
it's very rare speci and the UFC not a
lot of the needles no well these days
cuz they don't you know they don't make
their nut off pay-per-view so you're not
getting those stat card who does move
the needle besides Connor could be in
Russia to be he does yeah I think Nate
now does you don't fight often enough
but but there's a thing they does for
sure there's a thing about both Diaz
brothers that um
LD never fight again but I don't either
but there's a thing about them that they
are so iconic to like real tough guys in
blue collar America and and I love in
the American Hispanic community they're
they're [ __ ] Hodgins yeah I like I
always loved Nick Diaz the best because
Nick was this guy he looked like he was
moving at his own pace even when he
would hit he'd do this you just do these
weird like everything about him was he
was such a fighter and and he never got
put down the only John Daly not dropped
him with a left hook and then he knocked
John Daly out all day Paul de Leeuw Paul
think he's better for his John Daly John
Daly recently when he threw his club
into the brink take a look at how fat he
is sick oh my god he's so fat in this
he's just you see him he shows about
himself
definitely have a heart attack oh dude
he's such a gambler and such a drinker I
mean with the UFC none of the big draws
or they're all international here
there's really no American draw anymore
I would put those pants he's a character
man oh man he does look an help yeah
that probably feels good but when you do
it I'm very conflicted on John Daly
because a part of me really admires a
guy who says I know I should lose weight
I know I should stop smoking I know I
should stop drinking [ __ ] you
everyone there's something really I know
there's something very American I
believe that rebellion that that kind of
nonconformist but at the same time I'm
so it hurts literally hurts me like
almost in a visceral way to watch people
celebrate a lifestyle that's killing
people yeah you know like ours and Sid
Vicious you the list goes on and on
we're people like Oh awesome amazing
let's glamorize and romanticize this
person killing themselves on installment
plan you know Liz oh yeah I think part
of it is surprise that they can tell
it's a high level and be such a mess but
like um didn't you tell me this where
Tiger Woods John Daly with tiger was
going to practice and John Daly goes
tiger come have a drink of this for once
you know and he goes I can't and he was
like the [ __ ] is your problem he goes
I'm not as talented as you dude I have
to work hard at it yeah yeah it's just
like this lanyard is way more talented
than all of them but that's why is it go
yeah what were you gonna say though that
as far as American UFC fighters being
draws um I be he's not American but I
would you know could be ISM nilüfer now
yeah after that but that's my point
there's no American there's no there's
no American big draws did on Jones would
be does John Keller
he's not really a bit you know he's a
you know top maybe now in the world they
live in but you know you looking at all
khabib style bender
Connor has cowboy got into that point
because if just his the legend of cowboy
you know into an extent right lost too
many never became champion yeah we know
um he's a big name but as far as Ike
pay-per-view draw not not his thing
it's [ __ ] tough man it is check so
many boxes same as movie stars though
like think how hard is to be a movie
star it's very similar to movies now
because media and all its form is so
ubiquitous um it's really hard to break
through and stick with people I I
remember like in 2010 I think there was
you know 25 USC UFC events total
including fight nights including paper
views and everything and it was kind of
easier for for Brock Lesnar
Bisbing and any of the guys of that era
to really shine it's tough man when
glass when there's 120 events or 70 they
have to deliver 72 events on ESPN and
that's like 20 pay-per-views - yes I'm
like 2021 paper but seventy two events
on ESPN there's one of the reasons that
the UFC is moving forward and Dana
White's buying out Island did you hear
this no he bought an island so he can do
international fights there because he's
I don't know how long his kronas going
on I want my guys fighting so I'm gonna
make we're gonna take all necessary
steps to make sure everyone's safe but
when do the international fights on an
island and you're like there's a part of
me where I'm like I love that he's
continued get this done and it's
inspirational he's trying to get you
know society back to normal I love that
part but then a part of me is like why
he's so desperate to do this and then
you see well they have to deliver 72
events the ESPN to get there 750 million
dollars a year they have to deliver that
not because because the hassle [ __ ] you
pay me I don't care about Kovan no you
see there's a contract for 750 million
dollars with Disney I doubt they care
about any virus you know they're like
dude we deliver like it's a contract man
then we're losing money I think those
Myrtle [ __ ] Island a private island
so he's doing yeah you could even do it
on a boat like a floating oil or just do
an island you know that's what he's
doing that ship would be sick though
like a like a maritime fight where
people like helicopter into a giant
yacht yeah you could easily that must've
gone on a cruise ship Oh couse it all
tanked especially would know with no
crowd you do a cruise ship though cruise
ship maybe but you know how like they
did your training rooms yeah you know
how they do like old-school like Pride
style or WWE style entrances how sick
would it be if like as the card went on
you saw like the helicopter come on you
know is it that's like oh no here comes
[ __ ] yeah Daniel Cormier ready for
action yeah be sick yeah after that they
have to deliver these fights this fights
gonna be sick man people are hating on
don't like Jesus Christ I'll pull this
off in the corona times it's insane so
is this this is not this is not gonna be
where they're gonna host the gay a
Ferguson this is for later on it's
getting yeah that's that that's where
the fights moving Fiji Ferguson is it a
Indian gets you know right Indian land
for
in California maybe who knows yeah dad I
do like that is a China where it's at
but I can't say Oh national national
guidelines [ __ ] you
Native American lunatic in land how say
it's a Americans get a lot away with a
lot huh a lot of money a lot of moolah
they should didn't you yeah and the
Native American tribe like they had the
picture of the tribe that owned the
casino yeah they were black we did a
show it was it Oklahoma
yeah something and then Brendan and I
were there and we went to Cherokee
Nation it was very different
whit's his other like this other place
might have been up near Sacramento but
the tribe was let me wait the tribe was
there's no feather sir I know that there
was a lot of there was back in the day
there were slaves that had that that ran
away to Native American you know
strongholds and things like that but but
there was also a lot of intermarriage yo
do you say if you if you marry in and
then have a Native American child yeah
big that's never never tell you that
time I didn't appear is when I was
fighting I think I was 2 or 3 years in
the you see I wasn't living in
California my friend Sherif he's worked
for Tapout I love her she goes hey I've
this opportunity this a friend of a
friend is throwing this party for kids
they're four and five years old and they
won a UFC themed party but they want UFC
fighters there I'm like Jesus Christ for
these kids
you know yeah it's a whole youth team
party they have UFC cakes everything
they're the biggest fans so you go okay
I do it she goes they'll give you
$10,000 cash
ohyeah and they go they'll provide a
limo everything at the time I'll do it a
thousand sigh I'll do it now I went it
but at the time it was like ten thousand
was I mean why what what I saw Chico
[ __ ] yeah so he picked me up pick me up
in this old school limo they drive me
there it's like I don't know three four
hours and we go in this gated community
on this mountain we drive up and outside
this house it looks like bad boys to
Miami but it's in this Indian
Reservation this huge house there's
Bentley's McLaren's Bugattis just also
check I'm like what the [ __ ] you know
I'm a car game like what the [ __ ]
going on I get out I walk in the entire
wall bigger than this is a fish tank
sharks just all this cool [ __ ] I'm like
holy [ __ ] and I walk in it's like
training day Granite reindeer was there
with the Mexicans playing cards yeah
yeah so this all these Native Americans
and wifebeaters just tatted up from
their face all over guns are laying out
I'm here for the party and the guys in
the back I'm like no doubt I walk in the
back
I forget what other fighters were with
me I can't remember the life of who else
was with me we go back there and it's
like it's like Waterworld back there
it's like Disneyland it had like this
huge water slide out like the whole the
whole backyard was sick they have this
giant cake made out of a UFC Octagon had
like cages all over it nice the kids you
know what the kids are doing blow
fighting fighting like real fighting
here knuckle fighting Oh Shaw blurs and
I'm like the [ __ ] is going on fighting
fighting get him again I'm like is like
a toddler cockfight what [ __ ] man
so I talked I talked to one of the
people there it was like a handler one
of the fighters forget who this mean one
other guy but I was talking to her and
she goes yeah so these Indians on this
reservation you know a lot of them they
get a check every month from the
government and it's a ton of money so
they have no desire to work anything
like that so they just you know they
drink or that drugs they get tattoos
these passports travel yeah so they're
just doing that well you got my money
chilled there but once I saw the kids
cockfighting I like see a lot of
addiction in the Native American
community and that's they were super
nice I thought speculation I go to
meetings at some times and in the my
wife's from Seattle and so when I go
back to visit her family I go to
meetings up there near really highly
populated Native American lands and
stuff and you know it's a it's an issue
there's a lot of people in recovery and
a lot of people suffering is that
because it's like if you're gonna check
from the government there's no desire
cultural but I'm like a son of a
billionaire yeah like alcohol tends to
for many Native Americans is not a
Native Americans friend there's certain
cannon chemistry's there don't go well
without absolute that's absolutely true
and like people get weird about stuff
when it's when you pinpoint something to
certain cultures or nationalities they
look at it as like
like racist somehow our discriminating
but the reality is is like chemically
there's people who for generations don't
do well with that that's why that's why
people should know a little bit about
science when you [ __ ] prescribe
certain medications for example back in
the day when they were prescribed
interferon for a multiple scroller
sclerosis or for Hep C before they were
able to cure Hep C you'd it worked
really well with people of Northern
European or European descent it didn't
work at all with Native them with
African Americans so yeah depending on
you fall allegiance to you everything
around a big Hawaiian he starts drinking
Jekyll and Hyde man know if that's in
every time thing but yeah so she's on
the football team with a big boy named
vodka when he started drinking man it
was probably a Hulk a lot of its
cultural hues I mean I don't know if it
like if it transcends biology there's
cultural stuff to like it's not
stereotype it's not some discriminating
to say like you know the Irish um
certainly the the former Soviet Union in
Latin American countries they create a
lot of alcoholics
yes it's and it's part of it is I'm sure
biological but also with a lot of its
cultural there's a certain ties to that
that just go back you know a long long
time did you have any addiction in your
family just yeah I'm Mexican Irish down
the middle but and that's a tough clothe
my grandparents are immigrants so I mean
I'm directly tied to and there were some
my dad side the Irish side it was harder
to know because first off they all kind
of emigrated to different parts of the
country so I didn't know that side of
the family very well also they were
almost all dead my dad had his parents
and that was it everyone died yeah
everyone [ __ ] died at 22 or 30
because um drink alcohol isn't allow
machinery accidents yeah you know they
were there were one of seven kids and
only three made it it was yeah the Irish
side of my family from from Wisconsin
I didn't know any of them because that's
the same thing like they either they
they were fractured and everything was
broken apart and right but the Italian
side I knew everybody and I grew up with
you that's why identified
Mexican side - is that also because my
mom had such a massive family which is
kind of commonplace but they were all in
LA everyone immigrated to Southern
California and the other and there was
all this like extended family and
everyone on my Mexican side and so
that's why also I think I have an easier
time kind of relating to that side of me
is because it was it was the world I
grew up in you don't hear about a lot of
addiction in Italians
no not really right are you don't what
do you think about rich I'm sweet wine
they don't even drink like my my Italian
side nobody drank we never had whining
minute my often that much I understood
that I don't know I bet you you don't
you're like I could sit I could sit here
and say like oh yeah you know what I
don't tend to see a lot of people at
meetings and stuff that are telling you
but if we went to like New Brunswick New
Jersey or you know or Brooklyn I think
you know today I do I do think
culturally the Italians never really
drank a lot of spirits yes they drank it
was wine and even in Italy a lot of data
you get you get yeah you get already
similar to Mary's a lot you love but
only you meant mainly in Italy was wine
so you didn't really have it's not the
same man wine doesn't do to you
necessarily what because it takes more
you got to drink more of it you're
dreaming with food and such bro science
no it's not because I'm so hardcore
scotch man that doesn't oh no I think
Brian's right but I also think you're
right it doesn't matter you can
definitely become addicted to and and
practice alcoholism with anything sure
but certain different alcohols effects
you differently we're sure
let's not yes I well I'm not a violent
man but when I got drunk on Jager or
tequila I would wake up covered in cuts
and [ __ ] bruises suddenly about if I
if I got drunk on wine I was like party
man yeah some of it makes me that's true
- it's that wine kind of his seductive
makes you feel warm say he's with a meal
sexy whiskey tequila can you know you
want an idealist with tequila
bring us the Russia they were talking
this dude this reporter went to the
mines and they were having such a
problem with alcohol in the Russian
mines and she's interviewing than the
guy saying there's no alcoholism here
at all then there's a guy there's a guy
who comes behind them it doesn't know
what's going on it's so drunken they're
trying to get it out of there trying to
get him out of the [ __ ] this is what
says they're saying there's a lot of
he's saying they're no accidents here no
[Applause]
problem with alcohol it made any of the
minors denials a little hard to believe
please leaves three of you you just hear
it yeah dead it killed on the spot its
dad man like like that makes for an
amazingly comical youtube clip maybe it
is I mean I laugh at that it's awesome
but you'd like like things as that
happens after they're done filming that
guy's life is in a killer show is a
horse yeah or they kill them it's Russia
but you know worst addiction would be
food addiction because you don't have
you can you can get clean on alcohol
because you don't need alcohol to
survive everybody but you need food I
talk to eat as a drug out of three times
a day a drug addict and alcoholic I
always say it over and over again I was
like my greatest sympathy goes out to
sex addicts and food addicts because
Jack Jack I get you know I get why I was
told you can never smoke crack and drink
again that's did you know no drugs for
you I died that's it it's over and I go
okay so we get let's do this for someone
who really struggles with eating just
say let's get a grip on your problem
let's really work to get at the core of
what causes that and also mitigate the
outside kind of influences that can
because that can lead you back down
you're probably now go out into the
world and also make sure you stay alive
and eat every day but also you still
have to try that yeah drug that you're
addicted make sure you eat every day
after you have I never knew I never knew
the extent and what addiction was I
didn't understand it and I never knew
I'm so not an addictive person so I
didn't know what a real alcoholic was
until I saw one and I saw
drink at 7:00 in the morning simply edit
nine in the morning and then that's
impressive right and then at 12 and be
fine well I mean be fall down drunk and
passed out wake up and be in a good mood
because they were still drunk and drink
again
yeah that that to me is like if I drink
a lot the night before I'm so done for
the next four days I don't want a dress
Oh physically I'm all [ __ ] all right
great some people have a constitution
they say Winston Churchill and I'm a
Speaker of the House Tip O'Neill back in
the day they see he always had some
alcohol in the system all the time
some people just can do it yeah they can
just have it in their system and it's
unfortunate because when people try to
deal with real addiction real alcoholism
in in Hollywood often times it's either
glamorized you know you'd get like the
the this kind of like Jim Morrison slash
Hemingway kind of thing where it's like
I'm gonna start a bar fight and throw
caution to the wind and that's not good
on one side and then also alternatively
the cartoonish over-the-top way that it
is that it's presented to people it like
I'm like leaving Las Vegas what that's
not reality either it's it's a silent
baby someone's burning from the inside
out you know well Boris Yeltsin who was
the President of Russia I don't have you
ever seen this clip I'm gonna have you
bring up Boris Yeltsin this is the
craziest story he went on a trip to meet
President Ronald Reagan he or whoever
the president was at the time maybe was
Bush seemed think it was Bush wanyan
Bush Bush won
it's obviously when a Russian president
comes to Washington DC do [ __ ] it's a
big deal he gets drunk Elia um he then
he's he loses his security detail
they found him ladies and gentlemen on
the streets on the streets passed out on
the streets of Washington DC in nope
with no pants on like scott white now
that's now that's a that's a credible
source now take a look at Boris Yeltsin
drunk the best of Boris Yeltsin this is
the present take a look at he was
running
the country he's still alive
uh no he died and he was always he was
also always all ahead long a target
yeah but like you said Mike you can tell
this was this is vodka look at I know I
can say anything cuz well he'd be
President of Russia okay that's a rush
that boy in the [ __ ] Aladdin that's
better be careful with too much sugar in
the tank and run your little light in
wolfy yeah be careful I'm gonna just
vodka yes just vodka always strong Jesus
right this the sugar boy I mean that's
it is so bad he'd be but this is the
watch nose yeah yeah that seems plain
together just did that you sure about
that girl yes
he was a [ __ ] comforter you know any
Russian house here on the side Jesus
Christ have we ever seen a u.s.
president hammered never well I don't
know if we've seen about those days
Nixon t---minus
whoa which ones for some odd reason and
it came back to really bite him in the
ass President Richard Nixon insisted on
always recording everything that went on
zel ol Oval Office and arrived at
quarters and they were released later on
in life a lot of them after even past
you can't get enough of this lumpy
there's there's a there's a documentary
the Nixon tapes I think does he record
every conversation he hadn't though he
did a great job it'll be a great job of
holding it up in and from the public eye
but and behind the scenes in those tapes
some of its really sad what's is she
talking about Nixon's drinking really oh
yeah yeah he was very he was just
hammered especially during those days I
mean that job man it would lead anybody
to welcome JFK was it JFK was a drug
addict extreme drug my favorite present
extreme drug on and that's a speaking of
guys who held I also had style too I
mean no one no one performed better when
the public
I was there but the best the man was a
daily amphetamine user daily analyst
arena and also hired pros nonce now list
the list of [ __ ] real Cal drugs he was
always crazy and his style is that was
the only dimepiece president we've had
right like for sure I mean Obama's a
handsome guy but as far as I'm wrong she
was a bit of Diane was I'm saying as a
president though Jeff K definitely was
hands yeah yeah yeah Bush looks like
[ __ ]
Clinton's not terrible a lot of blood
chicks dug Clinton he is now looks like
copper and in Star Wars he had a lot of
galas ok dude if you're present how do
you not bust a ton of nuts Wow you're
the leader of the free world dude the
world is your oyster literally you're
supposed to be perfect then you know I
had that would be tough when you guys
dude you don't get to be president
without having some I gotta say how do
you the question is how do you be
president without busting nuts my
question is how do you become president
how does anyone and I don't mean that
crazy going through it logistically I
mean what what person wants that no one
does well either like it doesn't go well
patien clinton to half the world have to
be able [ __ ] hate you no matter what
yeah that's right
you're giving people no matter what half
the people happy have the people age
every time you have to murder a lot
you're killing that's the good god knows
how many Syrians and Afghan evil in the
blank you have to get your job you have
to decide on an exponential amount of
American bodies on your head where
you're like yep sending in a couple
hundred thousand degree my there it's
leading off on that oh but even sign off
on bills like it with health insurance
and jobs and like if you if you don't
sign this a lot of people are gonna die
it's also this too like I was talking to
Bush's aide one of his closest advisors
Demi Bush is a and that yes and he said
and he said see a lot of people think
that a president will can have a
conversation with the leader of a
country and tell him to do something
it's not how that works what do you mean
so let's say Chinese espionage so the
Chinese steal a lot of our Sikh
yes in no way can a president say to
President Xi hey dude you're stealing
out the [ __ ] cut the [ __ ] that's not how
it works
it would never work that way ever what
will happen is they will be having a
protocol a discussion and then a subject
the subject of it seems as though there
is less technologists there is some
technology that is being transferred
without authorization and that should be
something that should come up at a later
day if there's a way we can do that and
then they would have their
representatives address the termination
it's all this formality it's not the
president can't any like Trump would
[ __ ] which is kinda what I like about
you too and I bet like with this the
hell this well the W at WH o if you
listen to him with that World Health
Organization crops as [ __ ] and clearly
in China's pocket there's no question
about it
each other the videos China decision
China has huge influence over the over
the w-h-o to the point where the doctor
WH o his name in Chinese wouldn't even
admit or answer the question that Taiwan
exists yeah and and Trump was like we we
these [ __ ] guys under Chinese under
Chinese Direction first said that it
wasn't human to human contact
they said it would that you couldn't
catch it that way they they were against
the travel ban that I imposed and called
me wrong and I was called a racism he
goes and you know it seems that they're
very China centric they're very thing
goes they not favor of China but China
centric let's say everybody knows that
that China [ __ ] exerts massive
influence the Chinese Communist Party
not the Chinese people and so he was
like you know what I think we're gonna
defund it maybe I'm gonna look into that
I think that's an excellent threat
whether it's true or not I don't know
what the whe Oh probably there's a lot
of good in the world so I want to be
careful I don't know enough about it I
do think that they are a corrupt
organization and I like it he threatens
we might be four we give them twenty two
percent of their budget I think the
Chinese give him only like thirteen I
can remember a thing just a video John
insert you know right maybe not [ __ ]
well I mean do you remember even before
he was president he gave a speech
working so no no what is it
Karlsson no no he gave a speech before I
believe this was before he's president
but not it he says in front of people at
a podium he said you know Obama's not
dealing with the Chinese the right way
if it was me I would say you listen
[ __ ] really said that
yeah and he's talking about China well
China and you're is whoa whoa whoa whoa
whoa dude Jackson I'm gonna send you
something I'm gonna say that I want you
to hear you listen [ __ ] yeah
and I quote by the way like that's not
it's fluffy
listen man like they're not our end
they're not our al how you described
talking a president have to go through
the process of like bringing up a
subject and kind of like intimately it
sounds exactly like how you would talk
to your wife or a girlfriend top right
Chen I'm sending you something here this
is the one you said about B or did Eddie
send this WH oh that's the world health
organization receives vast amounts of
money from the United States and we pay
for a majority of biggest portion of
their money
and they actually criticized and
disagreed with my travel ban at the time
I did it and they were wrong they've
been wrong about a lot of things and
then a lot of information early and they
didn't wanted a very they seem to be
very china centric and we have to look
into that so we're going to look into it
we pay for we give a majority of the
money that they get and it's much more
than the fifty eight fifty eight million
dollars is a small portion of what
they've gotten over the years sometimes
they get much more than that sometimes
it's for programs that they're doing and
and it's much bigger numbers and if the
programs are good that's great as far as
we're concerned but we want to look into
World Health Organization because they
really are they called it wrong they
call it wrong they really they missed
the call they could have called it
months earlier they would have known and
they should have known and they probably
didn't know so we'll be looking into
that very carefully he knows and we're
gonna hit a hold on money spent
- the w-h-o we're gonna put a very
powerful hold on it and we're gonna see
it's a great thing if it works but when
they call every shot wrong that's no
good look here's the thing about him I
gotta say this I've never been a Trump
fan you know this from day one I've had
a problem this personality and there's
you know everything else all that said
there's nobody's gonna win I was wrong
when Trump is sober and he's when he's
sober when he's talking about issues I
have to say I think you spot-on about
China I I am not mad about the way he's
handling this crisis to an extent I know
I'm gonna get heat for this so there are
there are things about the way he's
handling this that I appreciate let's
put it that way yeah I don't I what I
just what I really dislike is as I'm not
a man who is a trump supporter either I
think that his behavior and his rhetoric
oftentimes does affect our country
negatively especially in the world view
issues um but but I I find it honestly
gross that there is an utter and
capability for people who are his
critics often I'm to even acknowledge
that he may do something well and and I
think that that's kind of really gross
and dangerous yeah I also think it's
dangerous to even with this Korona stuff
like he's doing some good and there's
some positive that that comes out of the
things he's doing and know everyone just
focuses on the negative no matter what
yes no matter what its worst of the
worst thing that's where you what you
guys do is focus against personality and
not on his ideas not on his paw he's got
very smart people around him and so I in
a lot of ways I think what did a lot of
like shots he's called have been kind of
right yep and so you know this is no
dummy this dude he's not a [ __ ] dummy
and I went back and I listened to
interviews with him from 1998 and I he's
been [ __ ] talking about China and
from the job from the job and a lot of
other things that I'm starting to come
I'm like you know yay and I do think I'm
sorry to say this that I'm not saying
that that we shouldn't be imposing a
lockdown I don't know enough about this
I'm gonna trust the experts CDC I do
think that there are a lot of Democrats
that are cynical enough to believe that
if the economy is real [ __ ] we have a
chance of getting our guy in
I do and I also do too here Bernie
dropped out today yes I think the media
is very biased you just found that out
huh I did and that is terrible news
because I I want a vote a think I can
vote for Joe Biden I don't think I can
he let he's been dead in three years
he's also uh Turley incapable of
speaking
he just has got some dementia yeah I'm
actually worried about do you remember
you you might not be I don't know why I
do I think it was cuz it DC Follies it
was a old kind of puppet Ron TV show but
do you remember in the mid-80s Joe Biden
ran for president he dropped out had to
drop out because he's cheated later I
cheated on like a lot yeah that's else
that's right something even plagiarism
scale and it wasn't like they've got it
all wrong they've got oh he's like [ __ ]
I'm screwed I'm out I'm out yeah and no
one brings that up I was caught for
plagiarism
did you ever see what he was like and I
saw I think my sis are my wife and it's
his sister
yeah you just he's just he's you know
some of those things are you just making
so many species over and over and you're
exhausted at the end of the day you're
gonna [ __ ] up and the media loves to
catch it but I don't he's always been
considered in Washington a bit of a
blowhard
right and there's a type of [ __ ] up
to like we all with everything that
happy if you're a professional MMA
fighter even if you're [ __ ] Cain
Velasquez it is prime you make mistakes
but it's the way certain people make
mistakes that you got you go okay well
that just that's what happens Obama made
gaffes but when Obama was making gaffes
he's a scratch that boom back in it long
smooth as it and Clinton locked in um
Joe Biden is like you're watching his
brain break yeah you know yeah you're
like it might just be although suffering
from some kind of it all happen percent
there's a glitch going on up there I did
he can't be President when I worry about
that I do try I would have voted for
Bernie man I really would have too much
of a socialist was not gonna it's rough
and I think I actually heard you Brian
bring it up on JRE it's a fact like
let's lest we forget the man honeymooned
in Moscow yeah I mean that you know I
thinks Bernie Bernie is a good man I
think
Berni Bolivia believes I believe he
believes what he says and he says what
he believes yeah and I appreciate that
so there's an authenticity to Burnie I
thought I liked him when I listened to
him on JRE I love my problem with Bernie
is just that he is
he speaks in terms of right and wrong
and morality god bless him god bless him
about everybody deserves healthcare and
everything else the who's gonna pay for
it is secondary and I do think he has
tremendous faith in a centralized
authority of state government federal
government and that that is more
efficient than the marketplace I don't
think he's ever lived in a marketplace
right I don't think he understands how
the marketplace works and viscerally and
and and so for me as somebody who
believes that a decentralization of
authority and and who believes in the
marketplace for the most part capitalism
I just don't I can't have a guy like
that's a great way to put it I always
looked at Bernie - I I agree that I
think he's the most altruistic
high-level politician we've had where he
where he's saying something believe
believes it it's not enough front he's
not thinking about how how well it tests
or how they talk about well he leaves
with any and the guy's been protesting
and standing up for free speech and and
socialist ideas you know yeah more
socialist looking ideas for [ __ ] 50
years I mean he walk it like he talk it
I liked about Bernie but every one of
his ideas always struck me as Tweaker
ideas we're like you'll smoke meth and
you're standing recoverable you days in
a row you're like dude we could rob a
bank and you're like yes yes that's a
great idea not sleeping just crazy
tweaking ball oh it is a helicopter and
an RPG and a [ __ ] Porsche and you're
realistically believing this is a good
idea is that it's poor you could pull
this [ __ ] on Bernie is like a free
college for everyone tomorrow but
there's no plan it just it's it's nice
it's like a loser it's this is a great
idea that's my whole thing with where I
vote for Bernie is almost vote for the
person more than their beliefs because
it's so tough for them to really do
anything so I vote for the person yeah
he's not gonna Barris the the United
States you know for him to the tax laws
he want to do and all that stuff that's
never gonna get past I had Trump some
credit again
you got to be careful with giving a
president too much credit for
or the massive economy of US economy but
you do have to say while he was
president if these figures are correct
and I've heard them from several
different sources lowest
african-american unemployment lowest
Latin that Latin unemployment in this
country ever and the economy was
gangbusters did until this thing so you
gotta give the guys some credit
yeah now let's take I want you to hear
this I wanted to send it to you take a
listen to Marco Rubio talking about the
real threat that China poses and don't
worry
but it's al if if it's a little long but
I think it's worth listening to it's
five minutes but I want to get your guys
take on this just in ten or fifteen
years you won't be watching the US stock
market you'll be watching the Chinese
market and they will be determining
whether our companies survive it'll be
us it'll be us on the outside looking in
and then Americans are going to wonder
why do we no longer invent great things
why do we now have to do whatever China
wants in the world in order to get the
medicines we need to cure my mom or my
dad's Alzheimer's and the answer will be
because when they were displacing us
your policymakers were too busy arguing
with each other and playing dumb
ridiculous games on a regular basis
meanwhile China was focused like a laser
with a plan and they executed on it this
is not a game I can think of no more
significant issue from the perspective
of history than what is happening now
and do not misunderstand me I do not
come here to say that I want to be
unnecessarily aggressive with China or
that I want there to be a confrontation
China is going to be a rich and a
powerful country and we have no problem
with that we can't have any problem with
that but there has to be a balance it
cannot be a China that is rich and
powerful and an America that is weak and
not prosperous because those imbalances
are what create wars those imbalances
are what create misery those imbalances
are what destabilized the planet that
can't be
we need to recalibrate this relationship
it needs to be rebalanced on the trade
side and needs to
protective on our national security side
it needs to be equalized and if it is
China can still be very successful
they're going to invent things they're
going to create jobs they're going to
become more prosperous and that is fine
we've been doing that for a hundred
years every person in this gallery
sitting in the gallery every person here
in the well of the Senate on the floor
everyone you know has products on them a
phone a belt made in another country the
issues not that other countries make
things and we don't reach that about us
dominating everything it's about balance
now watch this this is not balanced this
is headed to a dramatic imbalance and
the imbalance used to be they made cheap
things and sent it back to us so we had
lower prices that's what's happened for
the last 30 years
they made cheaper t-shirts they assemble
the phones cheaper and they shipped it
back to the United States leading to
lower prices that's not the imbalance
I'm talking about horses the imbalance
we're headed to is they are they control
state-of-the-art artificial intelligence
they control the state-of-the-art
quantum computing which means that
nothing can be encrypted anymore which
means there are no such things as secure
cars left the present United States one
day will not be able to talk to his
national security officials anywhere in
the world without the Chinese hearing it
because no matter what encryption you
put in they'll break it with a quantum
computer that's what that's the
imbalance I'm talking about the
imbalance I'm talking about is one day
we'll have a dispute with China on
something on national security somewhere
in the world and they will threaten to
cut off our supply of bio medicines in
essence threaten the lives of Americans
not getting medicine unless we cave to
their desires
that's the imbalance I'm talking about
the imbalance I'm talking about is one
where they dominate aerospace where they
are the nation that controls satellites
and satellite communication they are the
nation that controls 5g we're headed
towards autonomous vehicles autonomous
vehicles will depend on 5g technology
and China will dominate the world in 5g
and we will depend on it so we're going
to know the fleet of autonomous trucks
and autonomous cars and none of them
will work if the Chinese decide to shut
it down because they dominate
feel that's the imbalance I'm talking
about and if this all sounds fantastic
apocalyptic look it up research it and I
promise you you will not find a single
person versed on this topic that would
disagree with what I'm saying
this is the threat that we face not laid
some Chinese people well all I'm saying
is that I I never took this seriously
I love the international trade and
everything else but you know it you're
dealing with a communist party that is
focused like a laser beam that can do
things and that does practice widespread
economic espionage etc and has the
intent of dominating the world I just
play I would play hardball with China 1%
do you this [ __ ] up do you see how
violence against Chinese Americans is up
yeah that's [ __ ] the coronavirus now
that's me they did but we shouldn't
fight when I talk this way I am NOT
[ __ ] talking about Chinese people
anybody Asian if you do that you're off
you're a [ __ ]
I'm talking about the Chinese communist
government government keeps their own
people down I'm talking about the fact
that a lot of people got rich who are
aware that wherever they were in this
country because they deal with countries
if you're gonna be like holier than thou
just know that China the government has
one of the worst Human Rights records on
record to their own people yeah when I
talk about the Chinese no absolutely if
you [ __ ] with somebody who's too Asian
or Chinese because the Kurama you are a
dumb-dumb I mean if you're anymore you
see him eating bat soup it's kind of a
bat soup maybe baby say hey I like a
nice warm bat myself I mean I I find it
really insulting to when like it's as if
you were to insult Chairman Mao that
you're insulting Chinese people for
paying birth with it or you know what
I'm saying like no one would say if you
were to go down the list of terrible
things that the Nazi Party or the Third
Reich did yeah you would be like man you
must really just like German I don't
like yeah I don't like what the Chinese
do their own people I was there I went
to Beijing I got [ __ ] saw the thing
is when September 11th happened Muslim
Americans
the violence on muslim-americans yeah
yeah that's crazy cuz dummies want like
they won't know that their people are
the ones that did it kiddo win count
wait listen everyone gets scared we all
do a lot of us are scared right now
there's a real problem when really
stupid people get scared
bad things that's right that way we know
we talk on this podcast people listen
and again I'm glad you you just a
revolutionist yeah I'm really not trying
to I'm definitely not going bad on
sounds like I'm China China China I just
think it's been an eye-opener to me yeah
it's been an eye-opener for me
well and also talked to people who have
lived in China and come to America I do
you will get a very very sobering kind
of take on what it means to be living
underneath the Chinese government and a
lot of Chinese Americans especially ones
who have had a prolonged experience
living in China will agree with Brian
this is not only that I mean how about
we're doing a movie and my character has
to run down a dis Chinese guy who is a
me and we're playing cops I have to run
through the old city of Beijing what
movie this movie I did this some China
to a girl from glued to China yes
and so I have to run down and I have to
I have to apprehend them and that we're
doing all this thing and I get wet night
it's up it's that sort of about a silly
heist kind of thing I'm things happen a
pie gets thrown my face all this stuff
not really but that's up so I have to
get I have to capture this Chinese
criminal the Chinese government got wind
of the script because you have that you
have to present it over to their sensor
yeah right and number one by the way
this is after I got retinal scan
fingerprints and I had to they show you
a thing that there will be zero zero
criticism of the Chinese government when
you were here and if you do you will be
asked in customs as you go through in
customs oh well unless you define a huge
[ __ ] with a huge shadow to to size and
and and so here's what's even crazier so
in the script script is written about to
do it being financed in part by a
Chinese company a woman who did a lot of
TV shows there and I get there and well
I say guess where I'll shoot
oh my go what do you mean is they will
not allow an American to be seen an
American agent to be seen on Chinese
soil apprehending a Chinese oh wow so we
have to rewrite it for somehow a Chinese
person to do it
Oh Jan so we couldn't figure out how to
make that work so that came out of the
script so I've had some and then the
other crazy thing was I would noticed
that the woman running the this show one
other woman was like she screamed and
all that all her minions came and to
listen to her and I looked at the guy
who'd been there for who was a English
guy had been there forever he'd been
there he spoke fluent Chinese and he
said he's let me goes slavery exists
here my friend sighs I saw I never
forgot it man it's a very very hard
place um this was a lotta great things
about China I'm sure Shanghai supposed
to be amazing there are a lot of great
things about China I don't know [ __ ]
about China I can't say anything about
China exactly I spent ten two weeks
three weeks in Beijing and you hated it
my dad would record not my favorite
place well look but I don't know enough
about China I'm talking about I was
there for a very I know but it's busy
and what arable yeah and like a lot of
artists have shared that experience I
remember when was a big deal with
Metallica was that a lot finally allowed
to playing oh wow they had to present
their setlist a board had to listen to
those songs and they were told you can't
play this I even like for instant master
of puppets it's about government control
and let's run you're letting people
can't play that I can't play that here
coming it's that's I bet even they were
like that that [ __ ] bangs but we're
gonna have that here fantastic song but
nah that's my issue with socialism -
it's like I want everybody to be I don't
know I don't want poor people to be you
know hurting for dentistry and all [ __ ]
that I don't want that either
the problem is it to insure that you
would have to have if I come up with a
company I make a lot of money yeah
because I have a great idea and some of
them Bernie says I need 85 percent of
your money yeah because you're making
too much bye though so that's
confiscation by a central authority I'm
going to redistribute it that is
socialist it is imaginary there was a
fighter right imagine if there was a
fighter who is never forced to kind of
be up against
the ropes there's not gonna be a lot of
dynamic performances from that fighter
you know what I'm saying and I think
that socialism you know it's obviously
an oversimplified bro way to put it but
socialism kind of makes it so you're
hitting pads instead of in a real fight
you know and that's one of the reasons
why America has been so dominant in a
relatively short amount of time this
country's been around records been so
dominant in developing ideas in Indian
creativeness they can make money and
they can have a better life if they come
up with their own look at our friends
who are calm not only wait look at
Brendan Schaub who starts out and in and
figures out a way to ease a fighter he's
he wants to be a comic so desperately so
look at what he did he comes along he
you know you run the business he runs
his [ __ ] business with with the
podcast his [ __ ] guy who comes in he
goes how do I gotta get I gotta make
money as a comic otherwise I had he had
to make money he's like how the [ __ ] do
I do this how do I get butts in the seat
it's not on the fly the [ __ ]
comes up with these ideas they're
Brendan's the one who came up with the
idea of of great you ever knows how
everybody all every comic every comic
copies have you ever seen how they do
graphics you know graphics and Instagram
with the graphic cartoons you know came
over the whole idea that guy that guy's
that's patience hero and and you know
merchants you know different terminology
no giving around I ate the bad soup
Brian hold on so whenever it comes up
with t-shirts I remember I remember so
well he goes we're gonna sell t-shirts I
was like huh t-shirts he goes yeah watch
I'm gonna design but I don't have money
sighs yeah yeah but but I just trusted
this [ __ ] because I watched this
[ __ ] guy and I watched him
I watched you know what I noticed about
this guy and I'm getting to a larger
point he had no money when I first met
him he had no money he was [ __ ]
trying to fight he was making [ __ ]
you know nothing and he showed up we I
don't know if you remember this we went
to hang out he had a BMW M series he
could barely afford I'm sick and he had
this really nice [ __ ] jacket he had a
blazer and he was wearing fake glasses
the way like LeBron James did and I went
and I looked at him and he looked
fantastic I didn't I've never seen an
athlete who dressed up like this and I
looked at my go I go
that's an expensive jacket because yeah
man I only own one of these but you know
it's it's [ __ ] he goes I love nice
things
I love nice things it's what I think
about it's what makes me feel good you
know and and I watch this this
entrepreneur this young entrepreneur I
watched him turn this business and his
own business into a multi-million dollar
operation and that kind of ingenuity
that then was that then was copied by
every [ __ ] comic including Joe Rogan
to an extent fact and Joe admits to this
the marketing aspect of it I mean the
[ __ ] the [ __ ] comes
along in every comic every comic bit his
style in New York and in Los Angeles and
so what that did is it made all those
comics wealthy and so we've all seen and
especially me I I remember when
Sebastian Maniscalco who makes 20
million dollars a year whatever it is I
remember he was a waiter I mean it's the
four seasons makes 40 he makes 49 when
he was a waiter at the Four Seasons for
nine years and the story of this country
is people who come up with a [ __ ]
idea
make a lot of money and then other
people copy that idea and say that might
work for me and then it gets saturated
they come up with another idea you need
creative destruction you're not gonna
have creative destruction remember the
flip camera that went away yes well why
because we put it in our phones if you
had a council that had to decide well we
got to save jobs over there so we can't
you they would never allow creative
destruction you have to allow businesses
to go out of business so you can create
other business yes the creative
destruction that went into this [ __ ]
iPhone that all of us use including us
socialists out there is something that
could only occur in a society that
allows the marketplace to be ruthless
for people who can't keep up will to
your point be what's what's the last
thing Russia did creatively exactly the
last thing exactly and you know what out
were like that's dope right some of it
traditionally some of the greatest
artists that have ever walked the face
of the earth when it comes to music when
it comes to dance when it comes to
painting when it comes to writing
certainly and it all just ended it all
just ended around like the turn of the
19th century Russia just just just put a
[ __ ] wops key oh oh but before then
where you had Tchaikovsky yeah we're in
a coffee I mean it goes the list goes on
and on of likes of amazing Soviet art
and then it just end on
you know because they wouldn't tell the
government you couldn't tell you're a
Louisville go [ __ ] yourself you couldn't
have any kind of so much of art is
disturbing its
artists who are look at the Vietnam War
you know this is where I wear where I
start to look at myself if you look at
the the music that came out of here one
that it was all protest music hey what's
that sound something that's going right
all that stuff was like there's
something wrong with you know Ohio
[ __ ] uh Neil Young it's about the
shootings at Kent this was a finger at
that you know at and and Nixon was
paranoid of the hippies he was paranoid
of the artistic establishment oh yeah
thank God thank God and so you need a
reference you need a distrust of your
central government more important than
you need a populist that's willing to
give the middle finger right to our
rulers and to the and larger to my point
in a socialist country you would be
penalized for coming up with all those
ideas because they would take 85% of all
the money you've made that you've worked
so hard for you didn't come from a lot
of money you did have money when I knew
you you had no money you just wouldn't
get yell so you wouldn't develop to this
extent it wouldn't develop yeah you
would have had no incentive would never
have had that inspiration because you
knew man was a dealer ended like you
were going to [ __ ] drown yeah or else
yeah I must but and then yeah there's
something incredibly cruel about that
there's something incredibly beautiful
about that and that's what time I do it
I do identify with some i Bernie sander
to the left who says wait some people
fall through the cracks man there are
people that just can't keep up there are
people that just don't have the skills
and and we don't want to see them on the
street yeah and that is where the left
comes in that is where you gotta go [ __ ]
man maybe we do we do need government
programs there's no boys there's to be a
middle there's that's it's got to be him
it's something that I've really thought
about and it's it applies I mean I kind
of developed this idea of really looking
at Fitness at taking all these people's
questions over and over again via the
internet but the reality is the human
experience we can never say never and we
can never say always Brian and I can and
we can sit here in wax poetic about how
amazing capitalism is and the free
market and the idea of sink or swim it
is
there's exceptions yes it's not a
beautiful town and and to your point
look I think it was Martin it was Martin
Luther King who said that America was
built on the idea of pulling yourself up
by your bootstraps there's plenty of
people in this country don't have boots
that's right - and a joker that I wanted
people to take away and they just they
either said a masterpiece or it's it's
in sells being promoted and I know the
one of the important messages about the
Joker is that there's a lot of people in
this country who were [ __ ] at Birth
yes and have been abused and I've been
completely ostracized from all of the
normal social circles right and you
panics you can't expect that perk that
guy or that gal to make something of
themselves in this country when they're
just completely [ __ ] insane or even a
soldier who gets injured and had to take
it was prescribed opiates now is
addicted you got to have compassion yeah
I had I was putting my place by an
economist who I was like I'm literally
yeah it was I'm a capitalist and you
know and I was talking about Adam Smith
the invisible hand and you know I mean
the Adam Smith is the father of
capitalism my father Mark and she said
she was so great to experience he goes I
understand you do know that Adam Smith
wrote that book when he was living with
his mom did you do I don't know if he
wrote I don't know if you know that but
I was writing I I don't know if he wrote
a honey your laundry's folded dinner's
ready
dude hit [ __ ] me up yeah oh oh it's
great I was like she goes what is that
worth what's that word that tickles he
was living he was living in a bit of a
socialist because he had his mother to
take care of that illusion some people
don't have a mother some good I was like
[ __ ] man like you having your
nicotine patches on you I think we
should make force Brian to take one I've
been drinking today
I've been shaved my head drinking I do
stop even dream if there's whiskey here
I'd have it if there was cocaine in my
house I would go these are the these are
the vaults big boys but what power are
these those are considered the extra
strong that's damn bro if you don't [ __ ]
around I'm only I'm if I do it I'm doing
the five milligram patch I'm not doing
that [ __ ] brush
knock Brian's [ __ ] face it would make
him sick and now look something that
would be fantastic viewing put this in
my mouth just one yeah those are those
are babies that's not good do anything
while you guys load up on nicotine and
excellent drug let me thank you honestly
so hard let me thank you cuz I don't
know what the overall response was but I
got so many amazing like really
beautiful messages about the last time
you guys had me on and and let me thank
the listeners too because so many people
reached out and talked about how maybe I
struck a chord with them we want to talk
about addiction and talked about things
like that
and how they appreciated me talking to
openly and in turn that helps me and my
recovery yeah a millionfold and it's
just like it's really such a gift so let
me thank you guys and thank anything
you're one of my favorite families you
know and we're trying we're talking
about guests and our friends are [ __ ]
and we don't want to say the name
[ __ ] should be now yeah we should
well delete us terrify to leave the
house and so so terrified little [ __ ]
that port terrified leave the house you
Oh what our [ __ ] all the lives of
[ __ ] bunch of [ __ ] and I and I go
dude and you know this you Mike's all my
favorite people yeah Mike's local dude
and he's so good with it here every week
thank you guys i means a lot and of
course i mean it's huge for me like
online presence i got thousands and
thousands of more views on my all my
stuff and a lot more downloads to my
podcast so so thank you i mean a
muscular you're a muscular man with
compassion i can talk though yeah you
out it like you know we have you guys
seen there something really kind of
healing about it like like there's
something like makes me relax around
Mike my buddy
you know I won't say his name my buddy I
got in trouble weren't dinner very small
dinner for people recently my people
yeah not recently everybody sitting
there and I go no no it's a it was at
home outside by the way on a roof so
there's good ventilation and we were
being Koba smart I'm just saying I'm
waiting for this day
that's such as there will be one it is
you're fine so I'm the thing he gave me
would it's just kind of sweet
yeah that nice yeah
it's spicy right it spicy so um so [ __ ]
yeah oh so so my buddy says dude
I went to a healer the guy is and he put
his hands on my body and I was crying so
hard and I [ __ ] fainted with a friend
of ours yeah I love him and he's a man
and I go you're coming and I can't help
it does he come won't say any more than
that I go I just go like this I go I
can't help myself and I go hey hey [ __ ]
all right and everybody laughed for no
no because everybody was into it
everybody was like so what else haven't
ya and then and then I'm like I've just
met a lot of people like this and I go
let me guess did he have a chest gem was
he wearing sandals and then the only man
one the other person person's friend was
like in fact yes but now he's 65 and I'm
like uh-huh and I've just been in LA a
lot so at least they call him a [ __ ]
fraud I got and the person that was
telling me about it will edit their name
out sure let me and just went turn that
me and went just went dude I don't give
a [ __ ] who you've met I'm telling you
right now this [ __ ] [ __ ] works okay
and I cried so no [ __ ] and he came at me
and then I realized I said you know what
happened dude I know who it is you know
what happened I go you had a man a big
man who is an athletic big strong man
put his hands on your chest and he was
there to listen to you you know and to
feel what you were going through and
you've never had a man yeah that's why I
can I never had a dad never had a man
think about this most of us haven't
the man is his name rhyme with bleep
[Laughter]
yeah and but these you can swallow it
you're fine so the things so she said
what I says I go dude I thought about
this I in any man that would put his
hands on your body
Gateway and say rights okay that's
powerful do because all of us all of us
are so competitive with each other
none of us like I would never put my
hands on you yet for you and I we're
always locking with each other but all
our friends we're always [ __ ] each
other it's competition we live in a
world where other men are other guys
you're doing jujitsu with boxing with or
arguing with or try to get your point
across it catches you off-guard it's
like you off-guard Joey Diaz called me
he texts me was he was are you good and
I'm like I'm great man and then he takes
he goes I want to talk to him like why
no no I wonder what's wrong with Joey
he's literally just calling to check in
on me and I thought something I'm like
and I was like yeah what's up dude he's
like saying how you doing Brendan chop
I'm like yeah I'm good man he's like
what he'd up to that um he's like okay
he's going through our stuff like what's
the captured what do you need Joey is it
nothing I need nothing that stands like
I love you I'm like not only all right
not only do so many of us suffer from
not having that type of male
relationship but there's a it's almost
like a cultural American thing the idea
of being completely self-reliant yeah
for men is you know I I had a marine and
this man at scene battle and we were
having a discussion and he was opening
up to me about certain things that he
was dealing with and he was having a lot
of problems with addiction as a lot of
guys who come back from war do sure and
I said dude you need to you need to go
to a meeting or at least how you needed
a professional mental health
professional to talk to because this is
serious and and you're you know this can
go a lot farther south if we let this go
out of control he said you gotta
understand for me a man who has been in
the Marine Corps for a long time and
seen battle the idea of me talking about
my feelings yes it's like asking me to
fly yeah I know it does just not and and
and it hit me so hard because I didn't
really not only was this guy who's a
proud American who grew up with this
kind of cowboy ethic of don't you know
bury your feelings but also he then
became a soldier so he was further
encouraged to learn how to divorce
himself from emotion it makes you a
terrible soldier to be emotional to let
that affect your thinking to cloud your
so take him out of the world of the
world of combat and now he's a guy who
has created has found a lot of value
in blocking his emotions yes and that
doesn't really help much in the real
world we don't but you don't block your
emotions right because your Latin side
or they're very open and loving right
yeah it's really weird
super stoic to the world around you but
within the fence overly [ __ ] can't
shut your mouth owed it to people that
you let in to your close friends and
your family family is a huge thing even
I I have this weird thing happened to me
when I was like 19 or 20 where I was
running with really bad people who I was
buying coke from in in LA and some [ __ ]
went wrong and my friend of mine the
same guy who the cat issue happened he
was with it he loaned money to this one
of these guys who used to get his coke
and the guy took off and and and never
we never talked him again as drug
dealers do and I had cousins like
honestly I don't I don't know these guys
that well we've seen each other a couple
times at birthday parties and funerals
over over I was probably 19 at the time
over my entire 19 years I'd probably
seen them five times so on their team
these guys were ready to go find that
man and kill him yes they're like
interesting yeah like my dad my grandma
bonds are so high like don't you mean my
brother so close she's my best friend
I'm close with my family but we never
really talked like that I think my
brothers weren't old me's love me maybe
twice right after I lost fights other
than that never it's just awkward it's
just not our thing yeah it's just not
our thing but but then my my girl's
family who she's born raising guala Hara
Mexico I should talk to friends that she
grew up you know that she doesn't talk
you know like she moved from Mexico and
she was nine but she still talks his
people she's like you don't talk to
anyone from high school your child's I'm
like no no why would I right now or like
her family the right do I check in on me
like what do you want
I think what's wrong with you why do you
like this you grew up well I grew up
breaking bonds a lot I'm alright it's
not like breaking it's just like that
was that phase in life yeah and then I'm
over here now man so like my intentions
all my energy
engines over here me yeah but so nice
that I don't still love you but it's as
if you need some call me but I'm not
gonna check in with you but we're always
moving forward all of us we're always
kind of you know try and get someone and
sometimes somebody will stop you and if
it's a man like I I was in couples
therapy and I had a the therapist was
this wonderful guy he was one of those
guys who just really listened to you
like my joke is he sounded like he was
talking to a nervous horse and he and he
he you know he's just yeah and finally
he stopped me and he goes hold it hey do
you know what a miracle you are and I
went oh meaning is you went to a lot and
you've not getting yourself any credit
for getting through it with colors and I
was like oh hey man this is [ __ ] this
is not making me feel good don't make me
sing teacher and when I was 24 or I
don't know how old I was and he goes I'm
in the [ __ ] class full of girls that
I was like the hot girls I'm a young
dude you know how messed up I am about
emotion in with and also how I got a
macho complex and all that [ __ ] and the
guy says to me he goes I'm stalking and
he says can I ask you a question yeah
and he goes how come you never talk
about your father
why is he never in any of your work I
talk about animals horses and other guys
bodies with every dudes bodies people
can stop you and then he goes like this
you know what he did I forgot this he
goes he goes cuz I used to go and pray
in the dance studio
I would go practice Taekwondo yeah I was
still trying to fight so he goes like
this he goes and what is all this huh
yeah yeah I went oh wait uh you know and
he goes it's armor isn't it when are you
gonna take your armor off here because
it doesn't work for you
and then he made me stand there and he
goes can you stand still in front
everybody I go huh
you guys stand up take your shoes off
put your hands by your side now just
look at me for a second and I was like
this is when somebody makes you stop and
do that just that stuff it's very
[ __ ] disconcerting and it got me I
was embarrassed at certain and I'm an
emotional and then they then they start
asking you questions about how you grew
up I feel I feel like dr. drew he grew
up pretty normal right he seems to have
a shitty real very normal but he grew up
with academic his father was a physician
a doctor I'm very successful one he grew
up with a Eastern European Jewish kind
of so I expect a very high standards
very high demanding kind of type a world
and he doesn't talk certainly doesn't
talk negatively about his relationship
with his parents but he he has a longing
for a real softy type type of love just
lovey-dovey stuff he's he's super like
caring and loving like he's a doctor who
doesn't make me when you were like
tonight can I share your number dr. drew
I'm like yeah of course man he calls me
that brand I'm seeing forever man I miss
you like what yeah he's a misunderstood
guy and it's hard for me to sit back and
watch because drew does a lot of things
in the media that I don't necessarily
agree with furniture I wasn't a big fan
of Celebrity Rehab I didn't think that
was a good idea I think it's served a
lot of great purpose but for me I was
like I wouldn't want that he really had
this idea help of presenting the world
with real recovery like want and you
wanted people to see and heroes and
idols and seeing how they are also
struggling and and I great you and I get
that and I you know in the end it
probably was a good thing but my point
being is that I don't I'm not sitting
around sucking Drew's [ __ ] on everything
that he does I we have disagreements but
I really it really hurts me when I see
people online talk about true and say oh
you know fake doctor or he's a sham he's
a [ __ ] hack that's all about
attention because no I mean this this is
not hyperbole I've never met someone who
isn't an addict themselves who cares so
sincerely about people dealing with the
disease he is his
he loses sleep trying to figure out how
to get the the the disease to be better
dealt with but but those haters you go
not a real doctor or he's full of [ __ ]
he's a Hollywood guy but what else is he
gonna do that's the only angle they can
take what else are the bouncers gonna go
for yeah well you you don't help anybody
that's not true well you're not a real
doctor what are you talking about yeah
he is he's a practicing doctor for 30
years in Pasadena what are you talking
about yeah what that's the only angle
they can really you know yeah it I mean
that's the only place but also I like
does that criticism have to exist I mean
there's a it does there's a does it does
because that's the that's the world of
the Internet but it should my point is
is like everyone should be subjected to
constructive criticism yes yes um as
comics you guys know that that maybe
you're at the scent you like that the
highest level of we need at have we know
run real objective criticism you you
guys need it to succeed there's a big
[ __ ] massive chasm between
constructive criticism and people just
being [ __ ] to compensate for how
they feel inside I mean there's a big
difference I've gotten plenty of tweets
where people are like dude you need to
level out your your screaming into the
microphone it really it distorts it
doesn't you know and I think you're
talking a little bit too much about
yourself when you're dealing with
visitor I go thank thank you yeah that's
constructive I think some criticism
though what I think a lot of chrism
comes from is that you know you're doing
your job sometimes when you're speaking
if you get people who hate on you
because you might very well be hitting a
quarry triggering something they don't
want to face and the way they face it is
by lashing out yes my god but anytime I
see any hey again I barely see any but
have cat deal with most of it it's it's
their own it's not it's not a Brendon
problem it's them it's if they're
unhappy in their situation and they see
you're following me and you see somebody
flourishing and it's triggering
something in you so I don't look at like
it doesn't make me feel bad I feel bad
for them yeah there's my god
it's important to though to to kind of
filter out I would say ninety something
percent of it is that is like people who
are inadequate if you look by the way if
the internet was or like the real
internet was around when I was a
teenager I would be that kid I would see
guys I wouldn't I would secrets I felt
so insecure about all gotcha I was shy
which I would love her ever everyone or
something I would never reach out to
somebody who I watched on TV or if the
internet exists when I was a kid or an
athlete like I'll use I would just you
suck as soon as you do that to hear out
of the race the race of being successful
the race of making anything you're sad
about what you criticize you can't
become that was yeah you just because
because the guys you look up to would
never do that
they wouldn't anybody noticing somebody
because they're there they're just by
their presence they are an affront to
how you grew up in the things you hold
sacred not an example watching this Ken
Burns documentary car and everything Ken
Burns has ever done
baseball she has watch it all please
he's a genius [ __ ] him a Vietnam and
a series of many Tom his Vietnam is just
a his series on Vietnam is [ __ ]
incredible and I had a really he's a
genius he is the greatest documentary
maker of all time bar none when it comes
close no one he comes close to this
[ __ ] that's a weirdo yeah he is
amazing microphone injuries on the Civil
War
did you see Civil War baseball jazz
Vietnam please ones all different yeah
but this series you you want your loot
you'll learn so much you'll learn so
much Ken Burns he's just incredible jazz
that does pull all of it all of it
synchronize the Dust Bowl New York
please watch New York Brendan because if
you want to learn about the theater
history this country and the way and the
Civil War and based prohibition [ __ ]
might be the problems jazz and race
relationships and the strange dance that
whites and blacks have been doing in
this country from day one it's such a
[ __ ] beautiful thing but he I had a
really interesting IIIi don't know where
it came from but I was watching I was
watching Vietnam and and if you looked
at the people that were protesting the
Vietnam War yeah they were hippies they
had long hair they were wearing flowers
in their hair they were dirty they were
wearing sandals you look then if you
look at the people
were saying with us or against us they
were like they were clean-cut and they
were like [ __ ] dad let's let's let's rid
the world of communism and they were Pro
Vietnam if you look at them they were
they were they were it was the
equivalent of what all American people
look like my visceral reaction and by
the way the hippies back then were right
the liberals quote-unquote the left
wingers they were right Vietnam and I
would have I can tell you if I'd lived
back then
I would have been on the side of the pro
Vietnam guys because they were
pro-american protesters what I'm saying
is that I wouldn't have I wouldn't have
been smart I know me I would have had an
emotional visceral reaction to be with
America first guys yeah and not with the
hippies and I don't even know where that
comes from but I think it comes from
growing up with my father who told me if
you have long hair and a beard your your
pro-soviet or something right you know
what I mean so I have Iraq I have
irrational prejudices in my brain at 53
that I've had to confront we all do yeah
dude we can't deny that I think it's um
I had a really strange view of the
military and and and I grew up in a
world that was very we were talking
about how no one really opened up to us
as it as kids I know that I grew up in a
world where my dad was he encouraged us
to kind of deal with [ __ ] emotionally on
your own now we don't really need to
talk about that that's not how you do
things my father was a career military
guy until he transferred out into the
private sector but he was working at the
Pentagon you had the highest levels of
military clearance besides you know
maybe joints chief of staff and the
president things anyway he was very
high-ranking military Air Force
intelligence and was working at the
Pentagon during the Vietnam War and the
only time my dad's ever really gotten
like super emotional he was talking
about how he was this 20 you know 1 year
old guy and he would have to take off
his military uniform to leave the
Pentagon because if you walked into
Washington DC wearing military proton
and people would throw things that look
cool and he said so my left brain can
analyze and say that that was a terrible
idea and that
thousands and thousands of young
American men lost their lives for
something they should want yeah the
Vietnam it was a disaster cuz that but
at the same time it was something that I
K it was such a pivotal point in my life
and I had a community of other men that
we were literally living and dying for
this one cause and then to have other
people of this year same country shun
you for at any time it was so it was
like I had our friendship our ending
arguments I actually never talked about
this but friendship ending arguments
about Iraq when we invaded Iraq and I
was defending the invasion of Iraq
because I said that we live in a world
now where if you have a guy like said
I'm saying hijacks a [ __ ] country and
they're military they can accidentally
on purpose put a weapon of mass
destruction in the hands of someone like
al-qaeda and you'd have a mushroom cloud
over [ __ ] in Europe and I think we have
to send a very clear signal to every
country in the world that if you think
there's any profit and that it'll be the
end of your country and I was defending
the invasion of Iraq ah
20 years later on yeah I was [ __ ]
your right and I was wrong and I
realized I was wrong 10 years before
that and I was realized the friendships
that I kind of ended because of my
arguments because I was not very
diplomatic and I was an [ __ ] because
I was argument from emotion those people
were right you know so so much of this
[ __ ] they were right because if you if
you talk to someone who was in that war
the in Iraq they were saying they should
have left Saddam Hussein because when
that when they went in there which it
wasn't our business when they went in
there because supposedly had weapons of
mass destruction but we'd have any proof
when went in there and [ __ ] all that
equilibria the whole economy up we just
it made it what ten times we try to
restructure the Middle East the nitrate
arrogance nitrate hubris and yeah and
and you look good off you so that was
all that should I a new sanctions
apparently we're working this is all
hindsight but there were very smart
people at the time who were saying this
is a bad idea like my mother
Ahmir my father ganging up on my mother
my five foot two inch mother yeah my
mother said you guys are a bunch of
cowboys Rambo [ __ ] and learn nothing
about his and you hit her and then we
struck her [ __ ] it out
anti-american ass and we made her do
drugs and I said make me dinner maybe
look at me hey Mormon that's literally
what we were like though okay women dude
I don't have names just thinking of war
I don't know what made me think this
because we were talking as we're talking
about war
CTS real dude yeah I the few memories I
have my grandpa he fought in World War
two and me my brother would we'd stay at
my Grandma and Grandpa's house and he
was a Marine he was a he was a captain
of a battalion is what we call yeah
battalion and he was uh he was the you
know in charge of tanks but he's the
captain and me my brother we used to
fight all the time all over everything
it mean him got in a nasty fight I was
probably like six and my brother's eight
nasty if I was black busted let my
brother's vicious that there's blood all
over his carpet and he had to break it
up because we're playing checkers and he
broke it up and I remember I was I was
alarmed at how mad he was so upset and
you went it's obviously PTSD cause it
triggered him he's like you think I
fought in [ __ ] World War two for this
[ __ ] for you two to fight like this then
he goes on about this story how when he
was 19 in charge of these men they were
in Germany and he was in Korea or World
War two or two and he and he had to kill
a Nazi with a knife anyone on this long
story I'm like seven or I'm like what
yeah but shrim tell you given us details
of people killing this other Nazi with a
knife we're like what the [ __ ] dude I
never fought again that's a great murder
story grandpa can I go watch your
grandfather and me is I would have been
bragging about killing a Nazi with a
knife guy came at me
no I doct know he so he killed this guy
and then just you know they went through
his uh his pockets you know he had a
picture of his wife and kid was he
British who no okay American he and he
opened up though he saw his wallet with
a picture of wife and kids and he went
back years later to the wife and kid to
apologize
Wow he had the horrible horrible
resentment from it be and then he also
had this weird thing against the
military because he got shot with a
machine gun in his leg so he had to get
out
but when he was he had a bunch of money
like a bunch of money and the the the
when he was getting dragged away to get
on the ambulance whatever the [ __ ] they
do in the war they stole his money
American stole his money other troops
posed money yeah so he had like this
well really like he's gonna die let's
get you here watching you wanna shoot
but he was that money you saved that
money for my grandma who's gonna send it
back home by Mary he was so upset about
that to this dinky fingers cases all
sticky war war is not something human
brain is most experien no really
shouldn't you know it's it's some it and
then how we can kind of gloss over the
fact that these men are broken and they
come back to a country after doing
something that should put them at the
top of the food chain yeah which makes
them literally the most important people
to our society the people who
voluntarily go overseas to engage in
combat to keep us safe they come back to
a country and a system that makes it
almost impossible for them to function
in a healthy fashion it's so [ __ ] and
like Vietnam as a draft they didn't have
a choice
no no I'm talking about currently but
you're right there's this there's a real
real distinct difference because I
volunteered to be a driver at the VA and
Santa Monica here
Westwood Santa Monica kind of the border
there there's a VA and I for a while
maybe decade or so ago I would drive
around that's it they need to go to
certain a meetings are doctor's
appointments whatever it may be
and so they have volunteers to do it so
I would do that and no ifs ands or buts
there's a big difference between
veterans of Vietnam and any other living
veterans of any other war they're
exponentially more [ __ ] up well in
this documentary with Ken Burns they
said when you were a military guy he was
he wasn't one was a marine the other was
an army guy and they'd known each other
for you know five years or something and
neither one of them had ever even yeah
either one of them knew even knew that
they had both served in Vietnam you
didn't talk about it
oh so after the Vietnam in people
deserve shamed of it nobody talked about
it it just wasn't brought up in a dinner
or in polite company that
according to the documentary where it
was just such a nobody wanted to get his
a dark cloud yeah nobody wanted to get
into it's like a little bit like how
nobody talks about Trumper don't don't
bring Trump up at a party that this
you're gonna have people ago don't even
[ __ ] you so bad I will die and it's
gonna cause a major what's actually it's
actually calles of us civilians to think
that mean you would never expect anyone
to want to talk openly about sexual
abuse you would never expect someone to
want to talk about physical abuse or
anything traumatic and we we expect
someone to go through something just
disproportionately traumatic and then
hey but did he tell that for me would
you please come back to the society and
just do just get a regular job they're
like what but my skill sets to track
down people and complete the mission
like myself what do you you [ __ ] me man
yeah but the way to talk about things
now I think is this like don't bring up
liberal conservative socialist Democrat
capitalist I don't want to talk about
that I don't want talking about whether
you're a Republican or a Democrat I
don't want to talk about your liberal
conservative what I want to do is this
we have a problem there's a problem yeah
let's say it's gun shootings or whatever
it might be put it on the table I got an
idea I got some ideas let me give you my
ideas of how to fix that now if you have
a problem with those ideas don't attack
me don't tell me I'm an idiot right I
did this just idea that were given to me
to they just seem to make sense to me
instinctually intellectually can you if
you have a problem instead of calling me
a liberal or a conservative piece of
[ __ ] um can you beat my idea that I put
on the table with a better idea so let's
just match ideas and not be attached to
our ideas me and Rogan we're talking
about how important that isn't he and I
had to come to that because we were not
like that we're young men but as you get
older you start to go I'm not here to
talk about how high taxes should be
I'm here to rather say what is an
acceptable percentage that you are
willing to pay out to someone else to
you and and what that's it nothing yeah
do you think that's gonna actually make
it a better world overall because there
are some considerations
let's talk that way and not be too
attached to our ideas and not attack the
person that's our political discourse is
so [ __ ] bad and I
guilty of it too Bernie's a socialist
and I just dismiss it well that's not
true he's a little more complicated than
that he's got some ideas and and not to
your right I mean to attach people's
character to their ideas and opinions is
uh it's really it's really sad to do
that I mean also I think we're also
encouraged to do it with the internet
now with social media and stuff but
people feel this need to have incredibly
hard and cemented ideas and opinions on
everything and the reality is is like
there's not that much in the world that
we are capable of authentic aliy having
those opinions on my point being is like
when I you know two years ago when you
saw a lot of like the rise of black
lives matter there's a lot of people who
are like that's that's wrong you know
all lives matter blah blah blah I was
like well you really don't have the
experience of being a black American you
don't have that and when the women's
March was going around out I would come
before four-minute E's I was like wait
maybe that's not a I was like you know
I'm not well I've never spent one day as
a woman I'm in Philadelphia and these
women you better we are caught in the
March yeah yeah I'm in Philly of these
women are marked and they just
spontaneously in Philly just start
marching and some of them are having
like you know they got these like these
loose shirts on and this [ __ ] dudes
just goes blah blah blah I was show us
your dance
some old fat yeah yeah they're just
[ __ ] you know Philly [ __ ] Lutz
just Philly brass Jana show us your
dance girls look yeah God the American
discourse let's do Colonel very happy
with how strange do you think is on we
take a 4-2 raise you work out this
morning I did yeah but uh would you go
to uh got shoulders four days uses no I
did that I there's no access to gyms
around here so I did a little backyard
action I've been doing your trapped out
of your mind your doubts could I get my
swollen while Brian feels you up okay
now when after this we're gonna talk a
little bit about no I don't have your
I'm not a mesomorph like you yes we're
gonna bend lifting I'm gonna take hold
on let me show you what I'm working with
sick
no you're actually you're actually in
really good shape
serious boxing I'm so sore I get scarier
yeah you know you're in great shape dude
you're in great shape for a natural 53
year old you're in like upper tier dude
hey people can talk [ __ ] all they want
most people the overwhelming majority of
guys who ever walked by z earth would
cut off a limb to look like that at 50
that's just that's not true we you have
a friend that lives near me now named
mr. frank grillo who's your age and it
can show you exactly how to frighten
walk by walk by a wait ever since he was
a kid now he's older now and he's me
might be doing I don't know but but when
he was younger that dude naturally was
just super muscular he can put on muscle
like crazy I mean I'm talking about when
he was 23 he have him bring up young
Frank Rick his great genetics but
honestly though I having now met him for
the first time yeah he must train and
eat perfect you have no idea he must
discipline discipline because he's
disciplined it's weird it's very easy
honestly young Frank where I don't want
to say easy he was always let it's not
all that hard to be muscular to gain
muscle go go though did good when he was
Calvin Klein model go up there and
that's right
now we did when he was in his 20s
Frankie's I remember I met him back then
that was when he was every girl in gay
man in the world in the world like him
he was as legit Calvin Klein model and
on the Gracie on Hickson Gracie's
competition team obsessed with Bach
Sampson jiu-jitsu look it was young
frank grillo right there he had very
good genetics he has very good it's very
good genetics but also here's the thing
getting bigger or more muscular and and
gaining muscular weight not all that
difficult it you know you just lift
heavy you know linear progression eat
more getting leaner not saw less your
Brian not all that difficult but it's
the food for me man but doing both
maintaining that is so hard it is so
hard and he must eat Frank knows that's
a good picture yeah yes
Here I am a fun way told Frank will you
see his movie coming out boss level
wait'll that wait'll you see that [ __ ]
movie you might wait I coach tassels oh
yeah my boys head coach the great the
great coach of crew Vick he we had him
off or texted me immediately after our
last episode and he's a big t Phadke fan
and he said Mario Lopez would beat the
[ __ ] at Frank Grillo and I said you you
Tyson struggling but you wait one second
disrespect there needs to be a celebrity
right now especially if they were to
meet you know when the Frank is I'm
putting all my money on Frank and I know
Mario Lopez can box yeah I'm putting
like my all Mikey yeah I'm putting all
my but you know what Frank's just
tougher he's just tough that's probably
true Frank race tough tough he's just
any nose box and he fought I know for a
fact when he was younger he fought every
weekend and also Frank if you broke his
nose he won't give a [ __ ] you break
Mario Lopez Lopez's nose yeah what do
you think is gonna happen
no you're right I mean I see you tell
you in strikes are you wearing the boxes
every day with three guys chris van
Heerden a high level boxers water Oh
Spence I mean guys Brian Phil area you
know Brian from area let's go easy on
the term fight no no but I'm saying he
does spa retreat does works out with
them it rains hard I've seen this far
he's not gonna blow for both no no no
you never say an actor is going before
my god like Chris man here take it easy
come on have to just watch luxury do
here of course Jim here but but but
really studies the art of box
he's obsessed I've seen the guy worked
out even when I was in when I was
fighting he'd be in there I'm telling it
he'd outwork me yeah I and he was and he
spent a he was obsessed with jiu-jitsu
and there's also crazy and he's crazy
he's like a real tough guy like he's a
really tough guy you know like I make
fun of Hollywood for being tough guys
right stuff go fight you right now so we
were having this conversation on the
last jason ellis show who wins a
celebrity fight if it goes down
old-school UFC style no weight classes
you fight you continue going on like a
bracket okay tournament style multiple
fights in the night if joe counts he
wins right rogon row against who
celebrities celebrity the wall
celebrities i told you just a legit
black bow right i mean kick
to [ __ ] lunch and he's I don't know
the other celebrities well okay we gotta
throw in Frank I mean I'm just thinking
people who could even Joe Joe time and
not spraying dunno that's the thing it's
like I'm just thinking about the reality
of a real MMA fight
we're sure if it's just converted to
stand back and exchange blows there's
one but in the ground Joe's the best by
far the best celebrity grappler like
we're sure but but also joking kit
[ __ ] like crazy and ups good too
yeah he can back kick those spinning did
you take one of those to the sternum
it's you're done hot leg I don't know
that I have to know the other
celebrities because yeah some it has to
do with who can take a punch to your you
can kick and punch right hand off tassa
Chris Hemsworth in there I saw him
boxing boy oh really
oh it's a big 42 I will say the first
size right bigger than me I will say the
holler it leaner that's better looking
no one can throw kicks period that isn't
a professional fighter
Chris Hemsworth his Muay Thai look it
looked okay like I've seen it more time
I've seen his kickboxing in person yeah
and I walked in gym my sol's big ass I
did
I didn't register that was Thor and I
went I thought it was a maybe a new
sparring partner for me I was like who
the [ __ ] that in the ring back there
like that's doorman's Lee let's see
sense was he's a cool guy
let me tell you how I know has he has he
ever sparred or fought though Brennan I
don't know he's never door so I'm not
worried about it I think was the outdoor
one chin go up like his his throw your
kicks different see that's not bad it's
not good that's also three years ago but
he's got a on her balance big guy never
has he sparred what happens when he gets
jabbed in the [ __ ] nose there a lot
of things lot of things fighting so
different than hitting myths hitting oh
yeah
literally different sport I'm not
talking about him if I I'm talking about
that fact that we receive and try to
throw a kick it looks so bad and that
wasn't it oh that's a struggle is
celebrities right I can see any celebs
get punched in the face Brian so sad for
Brian count and I'm not slip oh I think
you have to remove celebrities that were
formerly professionals I think you you
are out Randy Couture's out obviously
it's quieter it's not fair Mike Tyson's
out officer look he's an athletic guy I
think he was that big he was at a
storage unit that I used to have my car
parked a stove a dad too and this is how
I know he's actually a cool person he
comes in with his wife who is [ __ ] so
it's so [ __ ] hot in here Upton oh my
god celebrity Elsa Pataky just busted
not sinner dude because they have like
60 he/she yeah I would be I would be a
never-ending stream of jizz inside her
because she is so ridiculously hot and
not a spring chicken and still looks
like that oh wow that's not a good
picture of her either
oh what's a good look there that that's
it that's a really and Chris Hemsworth
of course should have would you expect
anything less right right respected to
defy Matt the good-looking guy
I'm Matt this sorta aspirin sitting down
with the guy at the counter like signing
in and we're bullshitting because I had
my GTO parked there when I used to have
my my muscle car and he was asking me
about my car we're talking and Chris
Hemsworth walks in with his [ __ ] wife
and I'm like I'm just trying to keep
siding but he's you know it's pretty
impressive slippery or go and he was
getting looking at the like selection of
locks to put on his storage unit and he
goes uh what happens if I lose the
combination to this one what's the
difference be these two and then one
either guys like once you know you comes
with the key the other one is coming he
said well what happened if I forget my
combination I was like use a hammer of
Thor hmm you said that and he goes what
and the guy starts a very fun and I and
he goes what and I go use the hammer of
Thor and I'm thinking oh this guy's
gonna [ __ ] smears you he goes that's
good mate that's good and I was like ok
ok course there was a nice guy yeah dude
she's smokin yeah that's it that's a
woman he's got to send everything before
what is he something he's just Viking
boat up to he's a he's a Aussie isn't he
yeah his brother that's a grid it's a
punch
Haven to a lot of a lot of attractive
you have you been Australia that was a
little kid but I just like obviously the
media allows me to know that there's a
tremendous amount of poon it's really
coming out of Australia fit some of
those pretty girls in the world
oh you don't member her in Fast and
Furious she's not fashion for you okay
okay
37 years old watch the first one then
when they start jumping off buildings
and the rocks like holding a GTO by his
[ __ ] right hand out of a helicopter
like I'm out how well does the what she
deliciously celebrity bra when he before
he got Crowe because of his size and he
looked the man I think University of
Miami he's not he's not he's a legit
athlete he's got some toughness and he's
[ __ ] huge Samoan wallah huge now he's
probably not gonna make for the most
Christmas striker because of his balls
me stuff but if you get to hold you
that's a gigantic man that is lifted by
the fact we got a pleasure you talking
about weight classes right or we just
not when you tell what celebrity most
celebrities off my size there's a small
Rogan would choke the rock down exactly
easily yeah very quickly very quickly
yeah yeah I'll give some current events
you teach the rocks to compete with
Rogaine runs a black belt I think if
you're really big and strong it cuts
through a lot of years doesn't it it
does it Brian yeah it does is the rock
at his age you're looking at I mean come
a little black belt and do dude with
your strength against a black belt yeah
even with thieves my size black belt you
rolled up I know that I know but after a
year of you training with henna in here
on after a year holder destroyed and I'm
a black belt destroyed and he's my size
because you're wrong about that what do
I know that you're right Brian you're
not useless but you're wrong you trained
you trained for a preacher for six years
you trained for one year when you got up
with a regular black belt like me my
size
you're telling me that he was he was
tapping him out oh yeah a legit black
belt with a black out any big guy in the
world here's how I know well if you're
here athlete like you super
just super easy especially especially if
it suggests if it's just jack miss don't
worry I saw I saw exceptions Brian on
tummy those exceptions wrestlers Ryan
I'm that's the difference right I'm
telling a recipe like that Bubba I'd
lived it homeboy and I'm telling my but
you guys will see modest I'm not tell me
we'd get NFL guys in who trained for two
three years Brian Ortega would
annihilate them in 13 seconds annihilate
them
yeah Brian Artega is an exceptional
that's that's the special thing about
Jesus I've seen my entire career where
the big guy comes in he's there for a
year and he loses confident you don't
see him anymore because gets [ __ ] um
that's the thing about aachen time i I
belong just yeah for me like training
wise I prefer I'm obsessive about Malita
I love trained wait I I love it but this
the real special thing about jiu-jitsu
is that what Brandon's talking about is
very very unique in in combat if you
took it's an at-at former NFL player
like an exceptional athlete that's big
and strong and you gave him six months
of jiu-jitsu lessons and he really took
it seriously Kron Gracie had a hundred
forty pounds still gonna choke the
[ __ ] [ __ ] up he's so good I did you
make him go to sleep he's like if you
took you know a high level NFL athlete
and you gave him six months of boxing he
could hold his own he could be big he if
you know thinking like a really talented
athlete that's big and strong and you
just taught him how to throw a light I
mean he do stuff [ __ ] because a really
good boxer so you got all 47 pounder in
there you know who's been throwing his
right hand ever since he's gonna light
you up I'd still put my money on a
professional boxer but my point is is
that he can protect himself stay out if
you're a great athlete it's like the
different like baseball is the same way
it doesn't matter how high you jump how
fast you run if you're a gifted athlete
you can't play baseball
you can't play bass yeah you're right I
mean when you're really when you're a
big-time strong athlete you're a
270-pound 206 pound a sweet and you're
you're wrestling or Jiu Jitsu Eng with a
guy who's 165 you have a huge advantage
if you're athletic you have a huge
advantage you're gonna be able to a
little technique goes a long way you
along with a longer wait so for instance
we've I've seen how this plays out so
had her Gracie trained he was a six or
seven time pro baller he'd go to his
Instagram he just post about him
this kid used this guy this grown man
he's from Afghan to laughter African
descent forget his name play for the
Kansas City Chiefs pro baller three
years jiu-jitsu he's a blue belt every
black belt at the great economy would
steamroll this dude on a daily basis
that guy right there that guy right
there
o-69 pro baller Brian three years of
jiu-jitsu he's a blue belt as a blue
belt every smaller from small guy to the
heavier black belts would absolutely
have to see never my eyes because I have
trouble believing it I just do
understand yeah I've lived it brother I
know I don't you know baby dead hands
house I'm telling for 10 years I was in
the juicer gym we'd have big guys come
in there and they get [ __ ] up yeah I
know that get [ __ ] up that the guys
who get fired black belts will [ __ ] them
up but big big wrestlers I've seen white
belt college wrestlers that come in that
are Jack went up today
how about wrestling I know I just
wrestlers have different bears this
thing about me you high level wrestlers
freestyle wrestlers if they're jack
enough their bait doesn't matter how
good your bases to the other base isn't
good you know he's a freak of all freaks
by the way just a crazy ass six-time Pro
Bowler I mean let the legions and
training a lot huh I watched Henner I
mean you watched Henner like 275 pounds
Brian Ortega ties him in not yeah and
not just do is based off the little med
that's what it's for
there's there's plenty of YouTube videos
of like World's Strongest Man versus
jiu-jitsu guy or like I think there's
one I think it's Clark Gracie it may
have been
it's a Gracie taking on a giant
bodybuilder dude and it's you know it's
just a matter of time it's just a matter
of time humbly that doesn't it freak man
out the freak of all freaks I would put
myself high on the if you count me as a
celebrity which I don't really count but
if there was a celebrity Muay Thai fight
I'll throw myself high on the list
because I've even trained him for effort
I have for a long time and I love it I
taste it in my mouth when I'm on my way
you liked it and I I don't think people
throw in our I do a lot but in the
yeah but I I know like when I'm fighting
real competitive Muay Thai fighters
they're not they're not nuts you know
but they'll [ __ ] me but I definitely I
know what it's like the difference
between getting my my head snap back and
then someone who's like just moving
around yeah from when I take from this
conversation it's very exciting for me
because I'm gonna train and I'm gonna
take my jujitsu super serious is a and
in ten years you piece of [ __ ] it's
coming and it's gonna be surf and turf
but it's gonna be mostly turf it's gonna
notice to start cryin and then I'm gonna
surf you cuz you're gonna be on the turf
okay you understand me when I'm done
with you I'm gonna get on you like this
and I'm gonna surf you cuz you're gonna
be passed out and I'm gonna surf you so
I'm gonna get you on the turf and then
I'm gonna surf you dude and that's my I
hate to be shitty don't put your finger
near me about your hit here in ten years
let's go to current events fine on that
note I'm gonna let's have a grappling
match when this lockdown is over and I'm
not gonna train at all
you versus I'm training nothing dude all
right dude trip but I don't I don't I
don't I haven't trained I haven't put on
Aggie or rash guard in six months well
that yeah but you're still training a
lot are you a purple belt the blue belt
well I would love to roll with you but
you you're strong guy and you're young
and athletic and you've trained a long
time right instead I all done forever
but I would love to we'll do it you'll
beat me up beat me up are we gonna go
take downs from the from the standing
position any jujitsu competition that's
ever existed it careful now
right that's in high school and I don't
wrestle at all I have no refuge wrestle
in high school no Brian did yeah yeah
that's a you could just blast a double
arrest after high school I'm a judoka
guy okay let's not and I am and so a
blue belt hey let's not
oh let's before you have to high school
are me up if you ever touch me he says
he was going on my history American team
and that's not true at all no I can't
remember how I like said I saw a
mountain lion coming lying so you're
gonna wrestle in college we know this
kind of mischief okay so and he said pop
can I keep going down yeah that's good a
city in Louisiana decided that since
they're under a strict lockdown they
currently have a curfew from 9:00 p.m.
to 6:00 a.m. no one is allowed out and
police are patrolling the streets they
decided that they wanted to have a siren
to play throughout the streets they do
like one round around the city where
they police officers are just blasting
the siren letting people know hey it's
9:00 p.m. please stay in your homes
we'll see you at 6:00 a.m. the person
who chose the siren sound were aware
that they chose the siren from the perch
oh my and they drove around the city
playing that audio it's like gorillas
tell me about everybody out and some
people thought it was hilarious with
fire the [ __ ] bomb promptly after it
started gaining a lot of traction on
social media and a media app immediately
after the police chief came out was like
we are so sorry let me see that play
there's a city or the one on top any of
them the cops on her while and play the
person like oh my god what were they
thinking also no one else caught on no
was like dude that's from the purge
that's gonna freak away the [ __ ] down ah
seriously
Oh scary sound either know people are
toned up or someone's hysterical yeah
someone's really fine so what has a
sense of humor for the Louisiana Police
Department whoo you know Rory MacDonald
used to have his [ __ ] music Pixies
walkout music picked by some random
person ya know it's the craziest story
that Italy true it he changed his number
and whoever is involved with choosing
the walkout song yeah you know it was
someone at the UFC contacts you it's
like what's gonna be your wife he
changed his number and so this random
person who has Rory MacDonald old number
gets a text from Frank silver whoever is
you know and he's like my walk out songs
Ice Ice Baby
for like five years before Rory
MacDonald like what the [ __ ] why are you
playing Nickelback oh my god
you know Rory really well I really well
yeah I love Roy alright next one is he
the current champion or ya know he lost
okay so Tracy Morgan did an interview
online with the host of the Today Show
and he was so bored he decided to talk
about his sex life on live TV didn't did
she freak out uh no she was kind of
chuckling along with in the trainer show
[ __ ] funny when he's on he's so
[ __ ] funny being at home for Tracy
and his family oh well me and my wife
beat quarantine in it for like three
weeks old she pregnant three times every
week she got pregnant we and we also
we're all playing a lot now you know
what Tracy Willie took us on a tour you
know what's going on in that home of
yours there's a she was not feeling so
good what's that he's wasted looks like
an O you know what sucks but senior
what's up
I do guys play that because it really
been a long clip you guys watch this
yeah let me see what sucks is that that
was one little teeny burst of legitimate
actual humor yes on those morning shows
so and I guarantee you while that was
going on there were producers going
Greek in the make this star problems but
yet I guarantee they had a problem I
love it you worked with him before me
now man I've had friends who've worked
with him down let me see him is real
well-known for doing great characters I
mean your character the satyr nightlife
were great yeah you know for what I'm
thinking
Dominican Lou is over my head
was on Saturday Night Live for seven
years it was fun it was just one of Noah
Michaels is like obi-wan Kenobi to me so
you know since Saturday Night Live with
the Dagobah system
handsome now I see where I got so many
kids yes I'm telling about what the
Jaguars last night ladies here wow oh my
god
yeah so again not family I'm pregnant
Bret you hear me was not family and
watch two days somebody will be pregnant
so yeah Tracy listen my Mercedes I'm the
old child yeah that's right I don't have
wear ll god I got biscuits I got a loaf
of bread come get this look at that
that's a mating call so great pretty
much expected by the way he's doing
stand-up in that town that's [ __ ]
stiff you get the most if [ __ ]
who asked you these lame questions and
all you see is going along with it yeah
yeah but most of the time they're like
well anyway he's been you've seen him on
first you never see what can they expect
tonight isn't that it's not amazing
development though for the comic that
you are in comic you don't have to do
that it the greatest thing ever right
the greatest thing I still do some local
press
I love radio I came from radio radio
everything but there was very few shows
like the one I grew up on the Kevin
Devine show where most shows I know at
first hand when I when I did dance with
the Stars are other [ __ ] where I'd
have to do these radio tours you know
just be a phone or whatever yeah I'm
like wow this is not funny if there's no
middle ground
yeah they're [ __ ] terrible all
they're really good and the really good
ones a farm few between
yeah but there everyone loves specially
like celebrities from from the screen
love to [ __ ] on radio overall know
there's some really talented you know
Kevin be no longer huh the show yeah
that was pain and they found out like
the attacks I like for those outside me
not as yet but Kevin and bean were a a
morning staple he
many many years number one here in Los
Angeles but to have a morning radio show
for the same morning radio show in the
same market at the same station for 31
years
okay and then for them to fire them to
fire Kevin who bean had already retired
but to fire Kevin like he was some
overnight guy who got there a couple
months ago they should have the radio
wanted decision wanting to go in a
different direction
that's generation is it Nick Cannon no I
don't know that's power 106 right but
the thing I want to going somewhere fine
okay your business you're a company you
do what you need to do but they should
have said in three weeks it's gonna be
your last day we're gonna have a special
going-away show and then I bring back
that we're gonna bring back the role you
were going to bring back Kimball we're
gonna bring back Carson Daly we're gonna
bring back me know everybody's gonna
said we're gonna have it at a at an
event center the fancy coming out there
like um yeah so showing up to work today
is not a thing anymore that was it yeah
that's how they do their line he sent
out he sent out a tweet Kevin was like
man just got word we're not doing
anymore
so show won't be back tomorrow it's for
chid where they just don't care about
absolutely don't care there's just like
we got a bottom line some kind of
boardroom is never in it's not a k-rock
issue because k-rock is absorbed into
this massive media corporation they cave
rock itself had no choice his Clear
Channel still a monster Clear Channel's
a monster comcast and intercom is what
maybe radio gray was it was the local
guy like a guy like John dibela in in
Philly
he's been there forever he knows the
restaurants that he knows the how it's
all local she saw the city of it yeah
it's part of the city and you would you
would tune in because it was part of the
city and that that's like Willie's being
really being dim or still doing the damn
thing you know really be it all I know
of his kidney pie he's great greatest
but you know these guys are all getting
older too and it's like not not the big
boy in town anymore
not anymore podcasting and and this
serial so it's like a walrus model and
podcasting is it's made that that is a
it's it's over
that's over that is a it's dead okay
like let's just give up on yeah I'm back
on it there's a lot of value in
something like terrestrial free radio
but but what is this yeah every
is no different there's no need for
broadcasting when you can microcast yeah
because cuz if you I can only listen to
Kevin beam from 7 to 9 a.m. every more
it's like well dude if I miss it I'm
[ __ ] with this listen to it when you
when it's ready
that's right on demand what else you got
okay so Bryant Walker is the mayor of
Alton Illinois last week he actually
ordered a police police officers to hand
out citations as well as arrests for
anyone who were actively going out and
staying in like large groups of people
over ken sure and a couple days ago he
got a call from the police chief saying
that his wife was actually caught in a
bar at 1:00 a.m. with a bunch of her
friends and he had to go out and
basically apologize to the public saying
that he's very embarrassed but he wants
to lead by example by telling the police
officers to arrest her and give her the
normal protocol [ __ ] yes first or any
average first gotta do it he not only
looks like a hypocrite but he looks like
such a [ __ ] yeah it's his wife not it's
not like she was out at a community
gathering praying and [ __ ] she was at a
bar hammered with her [ __ ] female
friends at 1:00 a.m. you know what she
was doing you know for some but yeah now
she can potentially face up to 364 days
in jail or $8,500 fine show you fun fur
fur fur fur you know Wow yeah I guess
the situation was she knew somebody who
had a bar they decide to open and have a
couple of people come over they hung out
in the back but somebody knows that was
I didn't know that was illegal I thought
in either I don't think it's federally I
think it's been inserted but it can be
it can be you can be jailed for it I
think city to city state to state kind
of the rules differ we need to stop
talking about anything else right now
because my boy chin has on a Pantera
[ __ ] hoodie doesn't look bad and no
one has made reference well he wears
like a Pantera [ __ ] hoodie he wears it
all the time but I don't know what a pet
Tara you mean her discomfort of the band
yeah and Terra no longer no longer ride
a Pantera those are the bandmate okay
I'm back two of them died I said Montana
why did want that out why do they die
why did the bunk bed ah so the lead
guitarist Dimebag he died because he got
murdered on stage on stage
he was after Pantera broke up they
started a band called Damageplan he and
his brother Vinnie Paul Vani Paul who
was the drummer the Abbott brothers and
if they started another band and he they
were on stage I believe in Ohio and a
guy walked on stage while they were
playing and [ __ ] shot him point-blank
in the face
yes like you numerous times like a chest
head he was a military guy
I was pissed that any I think he didn't
like the fact that painted over oh sure
but he we didn't get a lot of info from
him because then the subsequently shot
and killed him because he was not going
out without a fight
oh wow we don't necessarily know like is
there video though definitely there is
Matt Matt Brown fighter there mortal he
was there he was there at that at that
crossroad I don't know if he was that
sort of a concert way to go security I
mean that's like it's hard to plan for
Duke and and this wasn't a big arena you
know there's like so they were starting
up their new band and this is probably
like a 250 to 500 what year was this
like 2004 [ __ ] I didn't I had no idea
that's terrible yeah went out doing what
he loves but [ __ ] damn dime bag that was
nice Columbus Ohio to son right
yikes terrible Wow shoutout to dime bag
is there anything else there's more
stuff I don't if you guys gonna keep
going pretty soon all right yeah we've
been good I'm set to do - two more hours
man Mike you're the best dude you guys
are the best thank you again for having
me I'm sure it's super short notice bro
yeah but I literally have nothing to do
when I lived down the block nobody has
anything to do we do we're not gonna
roll years gonna fight hi I'm gonna five
minutes oh [ __ ] soon I'm gonna choke you
so hard
so huh you you are gonna be surprised
that your hands will be a little more
full than you expect I believe that you
can you'll probably take me down because
you do have the experience in judo and
all that where you like and sweat I'm
gonna wrap my legs around you and you're
gonna get a cold oh you're gonna get a
feel of my grip and you're gonna go oh
[ __ ] what have I done and your
nightmares will come true you strong
cute I'm gonna grab your arm and yank it
across it then I'm gonna triangle you
too and I'm not gonna give up when you
tap in I'm gonna put them to sleep and
I'm gonna get up and I'm gonna I'm gonna
probably teabag you through my pant
really get a foam in your mouth now now
I'm I got some tricks up my sleeve I
carry a small knife tiny knife I'm gonna
cut you up a little bit
mark you up your back and stuff like
that you got a nice skin I'm jealous of
it so I'm gonna carve you up you're
shredded I'm gonna shred you up even
more clothes in a Boston Market and my
elbows might open up to my up a couple
[ __ ] a couple streaks on your face
you elbow me and I'm gonna push you off
I'm gonna get up I'm gonna let kick you
so [ __ ] hard that's what I love
you're gonna you're literally gonna cry
this is like in front of other grunge TV
I guess you know see me jump over leg
kicks have you what will happen is
you'll go I have to jump over and I'll
catch the [ __ ] like a football player
getting depleted like a wide receiver
come across your head open walk into the
ground and I will fall overlap well I
want to promote this I'll be the Dana
White it's me for 99 what are you lift a
lot you can move a lot of weight are you
very strong yeah I mean I'm not like him
but I for a guy my size I'm what are you
what do you deadlift hey what are you
deathless 520 oh my god what are you
dead left Brian not even does more not
even not even I know I don't need you
answer he does more that's a lot of
weight 5 how much like 5 20 but right
now it's 3 4 week since I've touched
away probably whatever 480 something
you're gonna face to the hell you're in
a fight Brent Jesus how much you weigh
180
what do you weigh Brad 170 yep this is
perfect but I'm not listen and April 27
to lock down I'm 169 what about you what
do you bench like 315 not anything great
I've never been a good venture lot
stronger than me I'm gonna have to
really go for ankle box I need to start
I need to come over the house all right
anything I will say anything below my
waist I have no defense I've know
nothing about like Renan
I'm gonna train some ankle lost some
knee bars do that again sorry
we love you dude I love you both that's
the final kid we're out